[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre jeu ph kanter
mois de dôme plan aujourd'hui on reçoit
les réclamations qui est auteur
animatrice candidate au doctorat
militante féministe très contente
d'avoir des doutes et si j'en et
oublient d'où des faits m'ont donné une
liste noire
ben moi je sais quoi du nez c'est sa
douce perdent avec les avec les années
en fait quand j'ai des mages à 10 ans du
saguenay de chicoutimi je viens de
secours durant puis puis quand j'y
retourne plus longtemps je reviens avec
un accent mais il faut que je reste à
peu près deux semaines
ma mère un chalet au lac puis quand je
vais au lac que je reviens je parle je
parle un petit peu plus comme celle ci
me direz mais ça fait n'ont jamais
habité de chiens de guerre dans les
laurentides gaudinois ya une tonne de
qualité motel qui est sorti des endroits
très chic white trash de communes pas à
chalais dans certains cas des nigauds
aura pas non
non mais je l'applaudis négoce et
d'enfants ayant perdu la vie et oui
gradé qu'est-ce que ça commence très
bien c'est après cinq minutes
merci d'être ici
merci à vous merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
on essaie d'avoir vraiment les des gens
de tous l'espèrent je pense que tu es
une star qu'on n'avait pas encore
exploité laquelle la spa engagé pense à
huy ouais
engagé comme ça parce que tu es une
personne engagée je pense que tu
mais je peux lui toi aussi mais moi
aussi maintenant moi aussi je pense que
oui je pense qu'il était un des
militants
pichard je te prends la personne la
moins engagés avant qui passion n'était
pas vraiment gagner oui parce que l'on
connaissait dit qu'on ne peut plus
longtemps
ouais c'est sûr puis j'imagine que
j'étais trop renfermé sur mon monde est
une natation et puis j'étais pas ouvert
au reste du monde sportif professionnel
parce que j'ai compris tout aussi bien
moi non mais enfin j'ai fait ça mon
secondaire
après ça j'ai arrêté de ses pigeons
j'avais pour lui
je le savais pis ma collec jeu content
d'avoir fait pareil la natation puis
d'avoir fait le sport études mais c'est
après le second d'âge comme passer à
autre chose je t'ai laissé sa musique
c'est la caractère lui continue et web
it professionnelles faut faut le dire
vraiment vite parce que ça existe pas
vraiment moins tu joues au hockey au
football le sport professionnel et au
québec le sait vraiment peut-être qu'on
a vite renoncé ce stand est pas mal plus
grand chose pour ptt compétition des
camps d'entraînement mais en même temps
moi je trouve ça très correct parce que
l'engagement ça vient quand ça vient
faut que ça vienne d'un coeur parce que
sinon tu peux pas mettre autant
d'énergie dans quelque chose puis je
veux dire on s'entend que au final c'est
plus une expérience humaine que tu vis
pu contribuer à quelque chose c'est une
chèvre une recherche de sens je crois -
moi dans mon cas c'était si ça m'a
toujours ça a toujours fait partie de ma
vie mais en même temps je vois des gens
qui sont encore plus engagés qui moi
j'ai des fois besoin de me calmer ça
vient vraiment sporadiquement j'ai pas
l'énergie comme certains de s'engager
quotidiennement tichri garde il ya
vraiment d'autres bois l'étau cégep avec
lui puis a toujours eu lui un feu sacré
mais tellement un temps spirituel à
iliad mais ya beaucoup d'énergie et de
cim incroyable manche j'ai pas subi
beaucoup de militants sont comme ceux
ayant eu beaucoup d'énergie puis je
trouve ça extraordinaire moi c'est
sporadiquement c'est comme ça c'est
l'énergie que j'y adhère
sinon je me brûle j'en parlais justement
avec avec jesse dernièrement parce que
elle est beaucoup plus
activiste que moi je le suis puis c'est
que des fois c'est la touche tellement
les causes pour lesquelles ce beau que
ça la fatigue c'est dur c'est d'y croire
que ça change pas puis de voir que tout
beau piqué compte une énorme machine une
roue qui s'arrêtent pas puis c'est ça ça
va peut-être se sentent être dur au
quotidien mais la dame il tanguait
villepiniste je suis capable c'est
justement le gars qui arrive ce qui les
activistes vigueur à manier fait chaque
jour justement aussi répondre autre
chose ce internet tout le temps tout le
temps argumenter sa monnaie c'est
fatigant d'être juste vivre lui aussi
oui parce que la posture de comme nos
engagements est plus facile sincèrement
se souvient je vais me taire puis je
dénoncerai pas où je prendrai pas
d'action j'organiserai rien mais si tu
passes à côté l'histoire quelque part
mais aussi ceux dans le motif d'
engagements at on envie de construire la
société dans laquelle tu vis non ça sert
à quoi
cio albert camus qui dans sa vie ça ça
quand même l'engagement a répondu à son
tout son cycle de l'absurde et de
l'absurdité de la mécanique existence
moi c'est venu comme ça d'un moment
donné en 2012 de me dire ok c'est assez
je suis tanné d'être dans le non-sens
pis ça fait du bien des moments d'éveil
collectif ne sais pas comment c'est dans
le mouvement viguen tant que ça je sais
que beaucoup d'adversité aussi est ce
que tu es impliqué également dans ce non
malheureusement pas encore c'est ça on
est sympathisant on comprend la cause
mais de l'adversité c'est tellement
difficile
ah oui mais surtout ça c'est un sujet
vraiment qui touche les gens ramènent à
ses personnels c'est parce que les gens
ces exemples j'écoutais ce avec le pack
je peux coller ma mère que je suis dit
que ma fille de suite mais ton
l'entrevue de jean philippe setbon à
part puis aussi tout
à chercher des contre arguments parce
que je pense que c'est une réaction
normale a déplu aux personnes de
vouloir justifier un comportement actuel
depuis toujours plus que jamais
questionner pis le contre argument mais
sa défense est automatiquement parce que
ça cassone ton mode de vie complet vrai
c'est beau mais en question nos
privilèges
les mouvements sont confrontés qu'ils
ont tout le besoin de dire non mais si
on va faire du racisme envers les blancs
attention quand on parle de sexisme on
va dire attention on va faire du sexy
sans voir les hommes même chose pour
l'alimentation je pense moi je vois pas
de contre arguments tant valide au
mouvement véhicule je suis pas vide une
pige et était végétarienne en ce moment
je suppose mais je n'ai aucune raison de
ne pas être végétarien et ville
je ne vois pas la logique de c'est sûr
que bon c'est si facile à battre pour
certaines personnes plus facile de
s'adapter à ce mode de vie leur pour des
familles c'est plus compliqué il ya des
visages des ajustements à faire mais
mais je trouve ça fascinant les gens qui
sentent est adoubé non mais non mais non
sont les faits il ya des charges de
automatique à 6 soit meilleure et tout
un mouvement avec je pense les fakes
news beaucoup de contre argumentation
pis chaque parole
et comme à lille le problème avec les
réseaux sociaux je vois des justement
parce que le je suis exposé à ce scrutin
on est un peu la cible de de ces
articles qui paraissent oui je vois de
temps en temps par être sont sur mon
fils d'actualités sur facebook des
articles qui comme de quoi l'aider si on
passait à par exemple à une alimentation
100% végétale on aurait trop de plantes
qui utiliserait trop de ressources en
termes d'espacé mais ça pourrait pas
être plus erroné
c'est parce que 80% des plantes sont
cultivées pour le bétail puis le bétail
en tant que tel prend une place énorme
juste ce cd arctique qui omet une partie
si une partie très raisonnable des
délais des faits puisque ça fait quand
ça apparaît dans un fait d'actualité le
moindrement qui prend pas le temps de
lire l'article que tu prends pas le
temps de lire qui réfute l'article ça
devient une information que tu as 6000
télé c'est le principe des cliques bête
si je vois maintenant un clic bay qui
marquait justin bieber trompe sa blonde
si je clique pas dessus pour lire que
c'était selon intel personnes dans un
bar une fois puis que c'est peut-être
même pas vrai bon dans la tête de justin
bieber à l'entrée ouest exactement mais
je veux dire on voit avec donald trump
c'est la meilleur exemple que le
mensonge arrive à avoir un n'est pas
créé a dans la vie des gens puis on le
voit de plus en plus petits mots moi je
le ressens dès que j'ai mes thèses
féministes bay à tout choeur sur les
violences sexuelles notamment qui dit
les statistiques sont erronées les
statistiques gouvernementales de
statistique canada ne sont pas les
bonnes donc là on dise donc tous ton
argument est invalide
alors qu'on est rendus là on est dans
cette réflexion assez dangereux
je crois parce que finalement tout est
validé et le détail ce raciste vont
revenir bon une résurgence de cette
enveloppe qui moi je trouve qu un
parallèle à faire entre le mouvement
mais le mouvement vegan le mouvement
féministe qui en fait les thèses anti
racisme de finitude trouve que le
parallèle c'est que souvent les
contre-arguments terre destructeur oui
mais ça a toujours été ainsi et on
rapporte quoi la nature de l'homme
l'homme doit manger la viande c'est
comme ça on s'est toujours alimenter
ainsi les féministes et bel homme est
plus fort que la femme donc ça ça
légitime certains rapports de domination
le racisme belle pourquoi d'abord les
blancs ont réussi à asseoir une
domination
c'est toujours l'argument naturaliste
que je comme mais il est un moment donné
il faut progresser mais c'est la nature
et l'humain on est capable aussi de
remettre en question remettre en doute
par notre intelligence notre conscience
des comportements qui sont peut-être le
juge poudrier certains contenus comme
comportement que sont complètement
erroné de dire qu'ils remettront une
race supérieure à une autre
si c'est lui qui rien qui va prouver ce
méli l'humain ou si on est capable de
même si même si traditionnellement
membres dans l'évolution de toujours
manger de la viande on est capable de
paul fort on a la conscience maintenant
urgent de paul farre pas parce que on a
évolué en le faisant qui est sa raison
d'être sur le banc à la fin
ouais exactement pitié le parallèle je
fais vraiment bien quand on apprend le
concept de spécisme wec et qui est
l'équivalent une oppression d'un espace
envers une autre qui est même même dans
mes marques et le racisme sexisme
justement c'est une faute accepte ce
principe le ballon l'a toujours fait
prend plus de sens parce qu'après ça tu
peux comparer à tour unique ans quand
les esclavagistes avait des esclaves
noirs il l'avait toujours fait et c'est
là qu'est ce qu'il ne fallait pas
changer ce une fois que tu amène ses
idées leurs pieds une fois que tu tu
prends par exemple dans le cas du
véganisme moi je le vois beaucoup c'est
la comparaison en l'esclavagiste puis
l'exploitation des animaux et quand même
réel tessa existe une oppression
dans les deux cas mais quand tu
mentionnes ce
la légende trade extrémités mais je
trouve tellement pas extrêmes et 120 en
psy c'est un autre élément et je pense
que les féministes aussi on a le dos
large sur l'énergie ce moi je m étais
d'extrémistes radical je suis la
personne la plus consensuelle même dans
le mouvement féministe
puis quelqu'un qui perçue comme plutôt
consensuel même qu'on me reproche de ne
pas être assez radicale mais peut-être
que les choses ont changé ces dernières
années avec certaines prises de position
que que j'ai eu surtout sur les
violences sexuelles je pense que les
gens ont compris que j'étais pas juste
la bonnasse de service parce qu'il ya eu
que ça doit sûrement le vivre au sida
dont on en mouvement mégane peut-être
que des fois c'est on y passe et on est
trop pour certains mais moi je suis
l'extrémiste où je suis la mole balance
vraiment difficile à aller chercher on
en parlait justement ce matin on est
allé déjeuner avec levier primo peut on
parler justement d'être ceux du fait que
quand quand tu es quand et nuancée s'est
passé pour les laits vegan pur et dur
piquante et pas nuancé ben là ça fait
peur aux autres pays c'est comme en tant
que figure publique par exemple c'est
quoi notre positionnement par rapport à
ça c'est comment qu'on fait pour être
accepté par le mouvement pour lequel on
se bat tout en n'étant pas rejeter par
le reste de la société
c'est difficile jean-philippe justement
et jean philippe cyr se tasse en chef et
gaouaoui qui se joue ici suivante suite
à son passage à tout le monde en parle
ça a été un consensus général par la
part tout le monde qu'il connaissait pas
que ça a été merveilleux petit que
c'était un entrevue génial qui a fait
que hudler il y avait toutes les
réponses y avait tous les maux suis
d'accord avec ce tir sauf que pour
certains vegan il était trop nuancé pour
certains je gagne a accepté de boire le
vin à tout moment par sa demande et
c'est un vrai régal
puis ça ça peut passer mais sauf quand
on tombe des fois aussi lors justement
c'est vrai qu'il ya des extrêmes dans
tout mouvement social puis dans tout
milieu je dirais mais se trouve que ce
c'est hyper difficile à tenir à soutenir
comme position ça n'a pas été évident
avec lui sincèrement parce que non mais
non parce que lui tant de zones n'est
pas de quelle activité la question c'est
est-ce que tu fidh
est ce que tu fais de bon à la cause ou
tant fait pour ségolène clairement fait
de bon à la cause mais mieux vaut moins
convaincu ben demande de changer leurs
habitudes cefac pourquoi pas je serai
jouer à 2 500 m c'est juste positif mais
tu vois quand on parlait de 2012 du
mouvement étudiant je pense que vous
aussi des fractions qui se sont fait
fort mais une tendance peut-être plus
réformé ces tailles marquées avec
solidaires et à un moment donné si c'est
une évolution dans les luttes
mais si je pense que c'est un
questionnement beaucoup de militants et
militantes ont en général est vraiment
c'est pas facile et surtout avec tant
parler d'adversité y en a énormément
dans leur cité
bon quoique quand tu participes à
occupation double à lasbordes aussi de
l'adversité moi je le sais pas mais il
ya beaucoup aussi des valorisations je
pense je sais pas ce qui est difficile
avec avec cette position là c'est que
beaucoup remettent en doute la
crédibilité des gens comme nous car on
est sorti on se faisait plus prend même
mois chez bourin faig me faisait plus
prendre au sérieux par le mouvement bain
par le mouvement part par le milieu
littéraire ce sujet le sait mais comme
otis par des publications sur sur
facebook par des commentaires en dessous
de mon article dans le devoir marre des
trucs comme ça mais faut plus l'ailé
comme sa tâche mais l'enjeu c'est sûr
que tu reste que c'était des gens qui
qui qui était du milieu de tiges puis je
le sais chemama professeur de maîtrise
aussi à lui un backlash vraiment
beaucoup de dichotomie dans ses
commentaires le thé certaines du milieu
parce qu'elle est suivie par des gens du
milieu certains approuvent et pas du
tout certain à prouver sauf chez que
j'ai perdu la crème du terran ce milieu
là puis aussi dans le mieux vegan s'ils
ont des six a perdu la crédibilité tiens
il ya beaucoup de monde qui sont
l'entente les branches lorsqu'il
personnes vont dire souvent devant nous
autres on n'a pas les branches que les
mots n'ont pas nécessairement respecter
ce que certaines personnes trouvent que
trop mainstream cd fois dans des
mouvements comme ça j'imagine que la
marginalité fait que métro quelqu'un qui
est en marche
cherchez des mouvements pour en marge
pour trouver une appartenance à quelque
chose d'un mouvement social type
certains qui sont en marge le regarde
sur deux au même si techniquement
probablement que dans les derniers 50 et
la présence de jesse occupation double a
été le facteur marquant
je pense que c'est une question pierre
bourdieu avait raison là dessus sur la
théorie dit charles c'est à dire ton
capital symbolique tenir comme
reconnaissance sociale battu collaborent
dans certains champs doit peut-être que
tu l'avais dans le milieu de la
littérature jeunesse vie j'ai s'ils
avaient leur milieu viggen machin pis
quand tu arrives dans un lieu comme
occupation double ni dans un terrain
tellement effectivement de
divertissement que saviez le obtient un
nouveau capital symbolique que tu
n'avais pas par d'autres instances de
l'usiné
donc c'est pas les mêmes que d'annoncer
s'appuie qui t'amène autre chose puis je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut que
tu vois les gains pis ce que tu veux
aussi faire dans la vie je sais pas
pourquoi vous avez fait occupation
double parce que c'était pour la game le
camp mais moi c'est une question le kg
pour 1 million de raisons et ben en fait
personnellement je 15 les faits c'était
on était à taïwan un sens oui l'histoire
d'un dans le podcast avec les ans depuis
on n'est jamais content
mais gros bâti on a appris qu'il était
en voyage ensemble que face à l'ob
revenez qui change un petit peu dit
marshall est un petit peu en au casting
sais plus mais comme le fait que le mot
j'ai juste dit à péage comme ce jeudi
toute inspiration c'est certain djibril
dubai world ont fait l'annoncé ce quinté
prix qu'il en soit ce n'est un peuple
j'ai juste lance au défi j'ai dit gamme
suit vous fait faire entrevue qui tu
l'as fait pour ouvrir en force en
voulant y aller j'ai parlé deux cents
pièces qui traitent de prix qui a été
britt et hebri pis ce défilé s'est
transformé en vrai désir d'y aller puis
je pense que c'était où beaucoup juste
de vivre une expérience nouvelle
complètement sorti un sérum le conforte
les biens sont conformes aux enfants
c'est plutôt à ça faisait 20 ans qui
étrenne natation et xorret que ce pilote
c'est comme une occasion de vivre un
conte santé d'expériences nouvelles
s'est sentie sincère sur autre chose ça
me prend un autre sens pour une autre
fois pour me
un autre quotidien parce que des fois ça
peut créer un vide immense lit quand il
fait quelque chose sur son état le qatar
est une retraite prématurée de retraite
à 26 ans mais juste de faire du sport
tout est calme
aude entre potes et peut-être que vous
entraînez un peu mais c'est pas comme
l'espace des pois ça va pas découvrir
dans les rues tisse peu fort tonnage
agacerait pour pas qu'on puisse aller
chercher un succès contre sincèrement
c'est quasiment une prison bah on
appelait ça la boys a évidemment ils ont
jamais vu ça à la télé mais on préférait
souvent tout le monde référence à la
prison de vitres à mon sens on voyait
l'extérieur mais c'est en voyant une
belle rizières en avant deux autres mais
tu peux pas sortir de là fait que la
prison soit en vitre ou en pirogue au
final de décoincer le carbone quelqu'un
qui ait la moindre amende et faiblesse
psychologique pourrait faire une
psychose la dame a eu il ya eu proche de
psychose plusieurs fois puis des fois ça
c'est une histoire qui peut être
racontée pich je sais pas si je suis le
premier à la sortir mais ils ont fait
appel à habib sy sur facetime
ah ben moi si ça en fait que je sais pas
quelle sortie comme quand damon avait
fait sa crise d'anxiété et en rade un
mot mais sincèrement c'est que c'est que
johan ils ont sorti des maisons à mener
pour une séance exception car venue
était déjà plus qu'un métier c'est
difficile c'est tellement difficile moi
je suis quelqu'un qui est ultra stable
émotionnellement j'ai jamais eu de gros
breakdown quoi que ce soit amené charme
on lit que je pleurais le tien chaudes
larmes puis sans aucune raison comprenez
pas pourquoi j'avais même pas quoi si
j'étais couchée dans le lit ça arrive à
toi arriver à n'importe qui ben oui
c'est ça ouais vraiment c'est simple
succès muschick écueil jamais je pense
surtout qu'ils caste des personnages qui
ont que son coloris pipe
peut-être pas des troubles
psychologiques mais c'est qu'ils ont des
baies en a qui ont des vulnérabilités
des finances a jugé ou qui ont des
traits personnalité vraiment intense
existe un cocktail explosif c'est sûr je
trouve que cette année c'est une affaire
l'impression qui est peut-être qu'ils
ont voulu jouer plus safe qui ont pris
deux têtes des personnages un peu plus
moi je tente les gosses en somme tous
ces cas sont différents mais pas
vraiment à l'opposé de qu on passe aussi
intense qu'on a eue l'an passé wen en
termes de personnalité qui fouleront le
terrain c'est clair mais c'est vrai que
c'est plus un lien plus est plus
ennuyeux par contre c'est plus facile à
regarder cela michael mais si j'en ai
dit je parle avis mais non mais parce
que beaucoup de monde qui ont qui vont
écouter ceux qui ont peu écoutés par les
eaux mais on peut en parler ouais parce
que moi premièrement j'aimerais ça
comparé avec toi du concept de
masculinité toxi parce que c'est pas un
concept que moi j'étais extrêmement
familier
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas un
concept que beaucoup de monde un concept
très flou qui fait processus là c'est un
concept qui est utilisé en psychologie
de plus en plus notamment par discodog
australienne qui l'a introduit dans ces
études qui fait une espèce de lien de
corrélation fait avec certains troubles
dépressifs ou autres et certains
comportements je dirais qu'ils réitèrent
une domination masculine genre violences
faites aux femmes à travers des
violences verbales
donc pour moi comme économique à l
occupation double et un coq qui pouvait
ressembler à ceux encore une fois cette
définition la haye et larges et floues
peut être un peut modeler à d'autres
d'autres intentions mais ça ressemble
pas mal à cesser de dire je vais traiter
une fille de [ __ ] je vais l'insulté que
j'interroge même valoriser à travers ce
je vais réitérer ma domination masculine
même si c'est pas c'est pas conscience
est très consciente et ça fait partie un
peu de lait certains rapports invisible
et visibiliser 2-2 sexisme ou de
misogynie quelque part dit souvent ça
démontre une grande faiblesse
psychologique et émotionnel je trouve
que dans le cas de michael il
il ya eu vraiment des sautes d'humeur il
ya eu des comptes des propos ce qui a
trait aux filles assez assez choquant
pour moi les traités de kaunas c'est pas
pas un usage du mot qu'une autre pour
moi c'est pas banal même si c'est un
français qui on a le même usage du terme
kyoto on obtenu des français dans notre
vie pillon kaunas
ça veut dire kaunas puis quand tu dis à
arnaud qui est renault à des
comportements aussi doute eu certains
vendus doit surtout dans la dernière
semaine mais les deux langues de [ __ ]
prostituée ce terme là je trouve qu'ils
avaient besoin d'eux comme toujours de
réitérer son espèce de virilité et y
arrive l'heure comme si lui toutes les
filles lui était du litre est un peu
comme des objets aussi les filles j'ai
remarqué ça ne serait pas quittera en
égal et donc un peu de ce chez michael
de masculinité toxiques et surtout par
la violence verbale
parce que ça passe beaucoup par ce
d'enfance qui veulent face avant le
contrôle et cette masculinité toxiques
leur peut aussi se réfléter dans des cas
de violence conjugale pittis la violence
psychologique se construit puis ce à
travers le temps excite europe puis je
pense que c'était un cas flagrant de ce
que j'ai trouvé dommage avec michael
c'est qu'on dirait qu'il ya paul ii oui
j'ai vu beaucoup de commentaires sur
facebook puis instagram qui disaient
ouais c'est la misogynie
mais j'aurais aimé ça que la production
fasse une petite intervention dans la
rémission comme mode et plus je trouve
qu'en tout temps la légèreté mais
sérieuses et c'est grave dire ce que je
trouve que ça banalise des rapports
inégalitaires dans le couple ou pas
inégal tam et toxique un moment donné il
ya des jeunes qui cote ces missions
l'ofppt des enfants aussi dans certains
copies des fois des jeunes qui sont dans
des relations toxiques humain qui
reconnaissent pas un comportement qui
est problématique parce que pour moi
c'est problématique le comportement
qu'il a eu une elle - même si à la fin
il braille et sa vie sincèrement ça
dénote encore une faiblesse lequel par
de faibles est fait
dans le mauvais sens du terme mais
quelque chose qui est une vulnérabilité
ses collègues qui exprime sa
vulnérabilité j'ai trouvé ce même montré
que je croyais pas trop mais je savais
aussi jouer la comédie mais qui exprime
sa venir habiter c'est correct mais ce
pour moi ça c'est important
l'année passée ils l'ont fait avec
joanie quant à eux des propos qui
étaient consensus des racistes sont à
lyon et sont intervenus parce que là
c'est le scandale
mais si on parle de type d'enjeux
sexistes sont ceux qui s'en foutent
ouais ben moi j'ai pu percer comme ce
nick et moi j'ai perçu
moi j'ai trouvé que tenu ces propos le
puits il le dit qui la réaction
automatiquement des autres membres de
tous les autres personnes dans ce show
le été négative ah oui ça
automatiquement quand les filons suster
comme michael est à mort il faut que les
filles on se sentait comme il donne
raison
puis c'est vrai que la réaction de
renault a été excellent sur le couleurs
pour donner ce spontanée pissas mots
comme rassurer - est la réaction des
filles mais je devrais en général dans
l'espace public l'envié mais quand ça a
été reçu en même temps ça me rassure et
parce que sur instagram
beaucoup de ces boucles
il fit et comme non c'est la misogynie
puisse avoir assuré mais ici pas tout le
monde qui pensent non mais je pense
quand même que ça le mettons deux pôles
mais je pense que leur protégé
c'est maintenant qu'il réoccupe et son
montage ça va protéger des crémants des
comportements salle a exposé samedi
génie je pense que ça décrit une
réflexion soit le fait de discuter de ce
qui le fait que ça a choqué le québec si
justement ça prouve que on a un bon
chemin de fait
ouais ben en fait moi ce que je trouve
le fun c'est pouvoir est exprimée
mettons ce point un flux de masculinité
toxiques ici ou là ou ailleurs si
chanceuse de pouvoir l'aborder ou du
moins de discuter
c'est vrai que tu as raison là dessus
une super action
je pense que dans le dock tu es vraiment
jouer contre lui
fuck le message que je trouve que les
missions envoyées c'est tenir des propos
comme ceux là vont jouer contre toi tant
pis tant que mots gg ça m'a pas dérangé
qu'il qui laisse à penser dans les
commentaires il y avait beaucoup ce
pour que la production de sa personne a
vraiment trop secret que je trouve que
ça ça expose quelque chose de laid mais
sale exposé au grand jour pis aller
les gens se questionnent avec des gens
disent que si les gens refusent ça fait
pendant cette conversation libre accès
bien là tupi doit citoyens métisse ou
mais personne n'a réagi dans l'émission
qui avait gagné mes tongs passion double
l'heure il y aurait un problème c'est
parce que son comportement a été
encouragée mais son comportement il
était puni c'est ici fake c'est ce que
je trouve que c'est vrai que ça
intéressant j'avais pas décemment vu
comme ça puis en même temps c'est vrai
qu'au des eaux un miroir de la société
c'est un identificateur mais pendentif
14,1 des formateurs mais il ya des
arrivées les affaires sur la société
dans laquelle on vit
c'est quand même une expérience
sociologique un peu dans un sens
vraiment sauf que là bas le consentement
des participants à la recherche que vous
percevez est ce que vous êtes senti
roumanie un peu justement laboratoire
définitivement ti-cats de la minute
qu'on a juste arrivé de bonheur quand
même dans l'émission où est ce que on a
réalisé qu'on contrôlait rien du tout
c'est où est ce qu'ils veulent garder
cette semaine fait que pire bien qu'on
peut faire vibrer pour khassawneh a oui
ça on en parlait souvent dit je voudrais
a amené personnes étaient contents je
prends l'exemple de joannie pis j'en ai
je l'enverrai demain je serai content de
la voir le tir parce que je pense pas
que tu aies pense pas que c'est une
bonne décision d'aller s'isoler dans un
endroit comme ceux pour elle puis je
pense que le temps façon à ford
mais ces personnes étaient contents que
soit l'heure ça rendait tout vraiment
lourd puis peu importe qu est ce qu on
voulait faire que ce soit pour elle ou
pour nous il n'y a rien qu'on pouvait
contrôler parce qu'on savait que peu
importe ce qu'on avait failli avoir une
touriste y avoir quelque chose avant
notre affaire qui avait fait recaler
rester là puis quand on a compris qu'on
contrôlait rien du tout le 10 ans comme
un rat de laboratoire mais tu avais
écouté l'émission avant oui mais quand
tu écoutes les missions d'un autre oeil
je pense que c'est justement dans ce que
le avec joanie l'an passé quand qui eût
l'espèce de twizz dernière minute que
l'aiea pouvait sauver
sandrine pour aucune raison valable que
si on a appris par la suite que ç'avait
été un projet sur roulettes il assure la
journée même ils savaient pas quelle fr
ce fils l'ont fait parce qu'ils sont
fait dire l as un beau pot
[Musique]
je pense que c'était la twist qui était
la plus évidente de toute l'histoire
d'une électrice avait fait c'est le
monde en a parlé puis je pense moi j'ai
regardé ça je regarde si j'ai regardé
deux deux émissions à waben deux
émissions deux séries avant de saison
puis j'avais jamais remarqué quelque
chose d'à parents comme ça sauf qu'aux
finances avait acheté avoue que c'est
sûr que le team jamais je n'aurais pas
qu'une et ça manque sa tête en signe
arisée mais je ne suis pas une adepte de
télé réalité jamais écouté au des avants
allaient passer super super talent et
aller prendre un verre avec le
libérateur de l'an passé puis on en a
parlé et puis ça fait tilt
ça fait du sens ce site offre aux
clients qui le spectateur ce qu'il veut
voir fixerez flottant cotes d'écouté
sera fait tant qu est ce qui crée des
cotes d'écouté puis c'est scénarisé les
autres leur survie qui semblait par
semaine selon qu est ce qui donne
qu'est-ce qui fait parler qui des fois
ci le dilemme entre et poétique mais
aussi à survivre dans le show il faut
qu'ils foutent fonction du puits des
forçats d'édition un peu sadiques des
fois les décisions qui sont prises tpiy
à une personne qui
car ce style documentaire puis pour moi
la vérité est tellement importante
gillham zara contourner la vérité et et
puis je trouve le respect des intérêts
très importants
en même temps tu essaies ils sont dans
une mécanique de production qui je pense
pas qu'il ya personne qui mal
intentionnés 6 juin je suis système qui
fait en sorte et ça pisse au cul sorti
tu sais maintenant je réalise à piller
écoute ça me dérange pas comme si je
comprends la décision
je comprends toutes ces décisions là pis
même que je referais la même chose dans
la position n'importe qui et c'est un
chose je veux donner un spectacle je
suis quand tu es pris dedans c'est plus
de ce métier moi ça me fait pas sur ça
intéressant sociologiquement justement
parce que et qu'on pense à toutes les
théories de sciences politiques de base
la magie du sens politique mais yo comme
tu mets des gens et je pense que c'est
qu'ils s'intéressent au sommet des gens
dans un petit milieu enclavées
donné partant des ressources une
ressource monétaire à la fin tu as un
appât du gain potentiel qui examine les
rapports de domination qui vont avoir
lieu dans ce lieu enclavées c'est le
même principe que par exemple lorsque
loties comme le principe de l'île de
l'île déserte et les ressources pis tu
es toutes les théories de la justice ou
s'ils sont un peu née de ce moi ce que
je trouve intéressant avec audi si c'est
aussi ça c'est à dire que vous êtes dans
un endroit en cave et il ya un jeu en
sciences politiques
le jeu du pouvoir locaux auxquels
s'adonnent les participants se dérègle à
ce jeu là qu'il faut que tu respectes
est un appât du gain en cinq 4000 places
est bon je sais pas quel point l'argent
est important mais on dirait que la
ressource est quand même lot est quand
même une motivation quelque part donc le
observons pis moi c'est ce qui qu'il
m'est apparu clair l'année passée c'est
qu'à un moment donné il ya des des
relations qui sont ressortis des trucs
qui serait pas nécessairement arriver
dans le monde normal parce que vous
étiez dans une situation exceptionnelle
c'est sûr sur tige jeudi rapports de
domination mais après c'est comme tu
veux je drc
c'est autre chose mais c'est la nature
de l'humain qui vient résoudre
je pense que pour ce que les gens aiment
tellement ça écoute et ce comme on est
un peu voyeur aussi en regardant ce qui
on voit on se voit en vous des
comportements hors corse et des
comportements grille assez des
comportements c'est très bruyant
j'ai réussi c'est pas nécessairement des
comportements qu'on aurait dans la vraie
vie des comportements qui parfois
peuvent t avec -6 visé outils mailei
toutes les barrières qui tombe pis c'est
ce que je pense qu'il vient chercher les
gens puis je reviens à alost
c'était l'une des séries les plus
populaires de soi puis moi je les écoute
et on avait jeté comme pourquoi ça me
fascine autant mais il y avait ce qu'ils
apprennent en même temps tout élément
qui rende en collant scénario et là moi
c'est là que j'ai fait aux acquis il ya
comme une expérience sociologique qui se
trament psy pas pour rien qu'il ya
tellement de chercheurs qui se sont
intéressés à la télé réalité c'est que
ça vient aussi psychologiquement sortir
de quoi mais j'imagine que vous en avez
parler peut-être à près de 2 soit deux
des éléments ou est-ce que des fois vous
avez comme des réflexions et nous on
parlait souvent de le film allemand qui
prend des gardiens de prisons des dix
acteurs vont faire des prisonniers et
gardiens de prison ces pôles ont
justement que ces acteurs qui sont amis
ou connaissances ou même peau d'une
personne égale dans la société
il ya vraiment un vrai rapport de force
qui se fait jusqu'à les à une violence
extrême de gamme en fait c'est pas se
baser là dessus je suis je me rappelle
on était au chalet à tremblant en
attendant la finale puis on écoutait les
émissions les trois co finalistes
ensemble puis est arrivée la semaine ici
à toi est ce que c'est la semaine
lorsque des six mois on est parti en
voyage en tanzanie
et pendant ce temps là sans répit
joannie avait vraiment jouer dans notre
dos et à bali thé avec les autres pour
les maîtres de leur côté puis on écouter
les émissions de cendres et je m'entends
super bien avec le sur un bogey puis on
finit les émissions de cette semaine là
puis l'homme je m'avance dans cuisine si
on parle pas trop le sens drake vient
boire il fait même
mais ce que je sais pas qu'est ce qui
m'a pris un ouais parce qu on a vu ces
réactions l'autre lui dans le fond c'est
probablement que s'était rendu au point
où est-ce qu'il a quitté rendu afin de
l'argent aux boucles site à tête puis
est venu boire puis mode image mais ce
que j'aime pas ça il faut savoir agir
comme ceux puis ça a été un déclic de
musées royaux même moitié on devient des
gens différents types ion on n'aime pas
recevoir cette nature c'est machiavel
ouais on est un peu dans le
machiavélisme là dedans tu sais c'est
comme heureux c'est aussi un oeil pour
oeil dent pour dent
mais si je s'écrit à cause d'une
circonstance c'est pas nécessairement
vos traits de personnalité ou quoi que
ce soit le mois probablement que je
réagirais comme ça un tipi après on peut
même faire des parallèles avec le monde
politique le jeudi il ya tellement de
coups de couteau qui se donne quand on
veut on veut gagner singh on est prêt à
tout certains sont prêts à tout
mais de garder l'équilibré dedans je
trouve que ça doit être quelque chose
c'est moi j'ai juste fait un stage au
burkina faso et en 2011 on était comme 8
faisait de la radio d'ambrose me
sincèrement il y avait comme des petites
tensions un peu à la hau des cages avec
du recul pour comme marquez piqué et oui
parce qu'on était en mode survie il
avait 18 ans 19 ans compétition travers
le trou pas vraiment écoute la
compétition là des fois à la rive
quantité à tort pour moi des fois c'est
dans la façon de faire tes projets des
fois c'est dans la façon de des trémies
de la communauté séance a jamais été
nommé puis-je jamais parlé de ça avec
personne et sa main mais avec du recul y
avait peut-être une petite compétition
le train comme à l'école où il y avait
peut-être de quoi mais c'est sûr qu'ils
avaient pas un gain au final il n'y
avait pas banal mais doit être à l'autre
bout du monde avec 8 personnes qu'on
voit tout le temps c'était vraiment
intense puis une fois y avait des
peut-être des dérapages qui aurait pu
juste et de voyager de faire tous ces
voyages assez fou là c'est incroyable
c'est comme si surréaliste
ouais du tamil d'autre que jose aussi de
que les gens avec qui si on choisit ses
amis dans la vie pour choisir les gens
qu'on sente oao dit choisi paul impie
des fois ça peut créer des frictions
exactement avec des personnes qui ne se
seraient pas retrouvés dans la vie parce
que tu te remettre réellement éloignés
mais le supprimant exact puis une autre
affaire aussi qui sait le concept
d'entre eux lui qui à chaque soir en
passant entre les questions que tu te
fais poser des questions que pose pas
dans vies tous les jours tu mets ton jeu
dont je prends pour exemple de ce qui se
passe je suis jamais amené à me
prononcer sur son couple il ya personne
qui me pose jamais de questions parce
que ça me regarde pas ouais c'est sûr
que quand tu es là bas puis laqué quinta
soit devant toi tu dis que tu penses de
telco
plus honnêtement je m'en fout sauf que
là j'étais obligé de répondre parce que
la personne me pose la question fait que
le train prendre position de cette
position-là devient de plus en plus
importante pour toi cette position-là
devient combotte tous les jours analyser
ça devient réel à ce moment exact et
puis à tout les jours tu te fais ramener
la question puis un chemin narration qui
se fait par rapport à ça plus tout
embarquer là dedans poursuit pis affecte
est amené à prendre des positions que tu
prendrais pas normalement parce que tu
t'en fous tu es je rencontre d'un gars
comme cédric dufoix avec lui ce qui se
passe avec sa blonde j'en ai rien à
faire mais oui ça me regarde pas s'en
fout sa relation ça me regarde pas est
ce que leur amour est vrai je m'en fous
ça me regarde
par contre quand tu me pose la question
j'étais obligé de prendre position du
canaliser et un exemple en particulier
qui est frappant c'est parce que ce
voyage final poppy jesse vous aviez vous
étiez un souper puis il y avait eu un
petit chez lui sur la page facebook de
15 secondes 1 où vous disiez cendres et
qui joue à nice n'importe conan c'est
juste convoité pileux les commentaires
étaient justes poillion dont il ya un
super entre amoureux qui font juste
parler des hopis pitcher nanana pleut
des commentaires c'est juste négatif tu
me compte après que pendant deux heures
et parler de vous vie de tweed et rien
en deux ans avait vraiment boosté
viennent voir la cam fonds aquiloc
donnez-nous cinq minutes
vous parlez sans dire que je n y pense
en vous un vouloir donner cinq minutes à
fixer sur les 30 secondes convoitises on
n'était pas content quand on a vu les
émissions ont été vraiment pas content
pour ce genre d'affaires le parce que
quelqu'un a vu l'émission ça apporte
quoi la réception du public qu'on est
sorti qu'on a appris que le monde nous
reprochait de parler tout le temps les
autres coupes ont capoté parce que nous
aurons réalité sa vie qui fait déjà mais
sont sûrs on a eu une dette à mener ce
type au voyage final dans un beach club
à bali
puis on va là qu'ils on passe notre
journée à aller jouer dans l'eau à feurs
wever et puis le alain charlotte et
alain surrans gukhool single la prod qui
s'occupe des dessins oui elle est la
voix oui exact qu'elle a mis à un ami il
est vraiment cool qu'elle aime quoi puis
lui tu fais ce que tu faisais ce qui se
faisait demander de nouveau appelé fait
bon lol comme un feu de camp sur balles
amorties akli les étoiles peeters
il vient me voir et didier
parlez-moi de l'élimination en cinq
minutes
puis après ça en fait on vous enlève les
micros il ya plus de son puits en fait
je prends du visuel
nous autres ça c'est comme si le bonbon
ultime c'est du moment est plutôt à la
maman avec jesse comme juste pour chill
et puis être relax et cinq minutes ok
par l'élimination
finalement la seule seule boîte qui on
note dave ses finances il vient nous
voir pour nous dire ce qu'il veut mais
t'es rendu là c'est tellement important
d'avoir un moment seul avec mon ainsi
que j'ai vécue parce que vraiment pas
6000 âmes et et j'ai fait un truc ça va
beauté fatale
c'est un documentaire qui a fait
beaucoup de controverse sur la pétition
la beauté parce que vous l'avez vu ou
pas mais je sais que les gens l'ont
perçu d'une certaine façon et ils m'ont
vu comme la fille distingue pour rien
comme l'obsédé comme la narcissique
chose que je ne suis vraiment pas qu'ils
me suis rendu compte à quel point des
fois le montage peut avoir une influence
qui ne révèle pas en fait qu on est
vraiment pitié juste il y avait dans le
dans le film avait comme des plans de
coupe où je me maquille et pts et les
gens vont vraiment trop premier degré
pied si j'avais trouvé ça un peu injuste
est dommage peut imaginer à quel point
c'est difficile de ce que les gens
pensent que tu es quelqu'un que tu n'es
pas si j'ose dire si vous n'êtes pas des
beach mais en même temps ça fait partie
de la game
au final ça s'est mis derrière tu sais
qu'il faut sortir de cette pâte pour
pelé compte c'est quand même plus la
peine de faire ça m'a mis très dur même
si les choses qui ont pu critiquer je
dis tu es content d'avoir fait de même
plein d'affaires incroyable ici une
expérience tellement comme c'est une
expérience que je pense que j'imagine
que personne peut vous comprendre à
penser qu'ils ont véhicule on sait
exactement par les taxes et puis on en
parle quand même moment est-ce que vous
en parlez trop à ton avis des stalles et
d'en parler dans le nom parce qu'à
chaque personne n'a bien sûr de façon
différente c'est comme l'addition qu'on
a en ce moment on parle daudet mais on
n'a jamais dit non avec les rapports de
force plus je trouve ça super
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que ces
expériences pis
c'est à chaque fois qu'on ait une
discussion par rapport à faire le
spectacle quelqu'un comme un point de
vue différent
c'est sûr que je suis un peu tanné de me
faire dire tellement préféré parler
c'est vraiment y as tu vraiment comme
beaucoup de monde qui viennent voir au
salon du yacht et il possède encore non
le salon du livre c'est seal saint jean
de maurienne
c'est cool je pensais que j'allais me
retrouver au salon du livre mon premier
saut à l'excès avec je les croisais
c'est drôle on sait c'est exact aller
courir jeudi passé piller théo renaut
brice new delhi en reviennent notre 5 kg
de course
là c'est juste à côté du renaud bray où
on était partis pleut on passe devant le
jld a regardé comme celle ci il signa
personnellement lui fait quart partant
on est allé le livre que c'est une
expérience mais je t'avertis il
arrêterait sic de québec
c'est vrai que l'air est très sec moi
j'aï les salons du livre mais ce sont le
sais c'est pas moi j'ai jamais vraiment
je préfère rencontrer les auteurs
ah oui c'est le fun mais je préfère être
une petite librairie et chez kelly prend
le temps que dalila pour avoir des scans
de 15% puis happy sont costauds geely
ouais c'est parce que mais en même temps
c'est ça va te permettre de rencontrer
des gens puis s'écroule standing
l'alsace et ses quelque chose ben c'est
au moins ça c'est cool non s'ils font
une analyse fine avec ce livre il ya
beaucoup de monde qui nous avons
d'historique long avec pierre c'est une
femme d'affaires un lit vous cite ici de
six noms afin qu'elle joue la baule avec
toi je suppose une halte à tout le temps
infini away qui coule et de faire tes
études parce que c'est andric entrevue
je souhaite d'abord d'un truc parfait sa
formation professionnelle je quelqu'un
qui est curieuse vraiment bonne qu'elle
priait ça m'intrigue de savoir comment
ses conseillers la maîtrise tout le
reste à côté pas seulement une
concentration folle chose à manger sur
la tête il faut que je prenne le temps
de me concentrer puis ça m'a pris du
temps à retrouver une routine de travail
j'ai fait qu'ottawa de nos travers mais
moi ma routine de travail le matin j'ai
aussi mais toi tu composes je fais la
musique aussi donc c'est un peu le même
ou de création qu'il faut chercher
donc si ça le matin je me réveille pi2
entre 9h et 12h c'est ma période de
concentration de d'écriture que ce soit
écrire mes projets de livres où que ce
soit ma thèse de doctorat lié jeune j'ai
réalisé que je ne pouvais pas travailler
plus que 3 4 heures de façon
intellectuellement c'est beaucoup mules
et non par jour des jeux beaucoup de
michel fait j'ai aussi appris donc ça
c'est ma routine de travail de création
voit ce que j'inclus situe à un moment
j'ai cru à un autre et c'est donc ce
jeune un culot
9 à 12h après ça en général il faut que
je fasse du sport
non je suis pas bien dans ma peau y est
parfois bon il ya du ménage et décide me
rends compte qu'il leur est fait après
midi tout ce qui est social se fait
l'après midi mais même en période de
création et le matin puis des fois le
soir après le super challenge est finie
et sinon je prends du temps j'ai un
chalet avec mon amoureux qui on est
souvent chalet mais ce scénario est loin
valmorel si vous voulez venir un jour
créer ou chalets well as vraiment sévère
pour écrire la cfu moi ça me prend la
nature aussi me manque terriblement à
écoute
ouais j'ai besoin nature danville c'est
ici fondamentale donc les week-ends je
suis en chalet
je suis dans ma période de création mais
pour accepter aussi que la période de
création pour moi que ce soit la thèse
de doc il ya pas toujours été évidente à
écrire parce qu'il ya des bouts plata et
chris bosh pour figo lokeren tasse de 2
mai 6e des fois ça vient par g il faut
accepter calmement d'année deux semaines
de temps tu touches pas ton truc là soit
quand même de 9 à 12h mais c'est exact
obligatoirement s'inscrire plus pauvres
est ce que tu décris le c'est la clé du
succès c'est la discipline
ouais je suis extrêmement discipliné
mais je pense que vous l'êtes aussi
parce que vous avez fait de la natation
pis après ça la natation le sport ça
aide vraiment ça développe ce trait de
personnalité le de la discipline qui est
super bon puis moi je suis c'est spécial
parce que je suis comme un petit des
guides un peu enlevé le plan émotionnel
j'ai appris la discipline focus ce toit
le tnt
une des personnes les plus de 10 ans que
je suis allé en vacances au fait que
pour le niveau de tva que je te connais
tu es tellement fonctionnelles - c'est
fou le moins mais c'est pas facile
c'est un défi à chaque jour puis qui en
plus de faire de la musique c'est que je
sais que je dois avoir une routine c'est
deux fois plus tôt parce que son âge sa
route jusqu'aux chine où je mange pas
vraiment déséquilibre pitié justement le
lite et des eaux une des clés du succès
justement c'est d'abord une routine
stable c'est d'avoir un cadre dans
lequel je te manque pour votre question
petit peu désorganisé parce qu'une faute
idée d'organiser ces deux fois plus
d'efforts de réorganiser puis moi je me
beaucoup ma vie est un combo consultent
ce parce que si tu es musicien est ce
que tu fais beaucoup de tournées je fais
beaucoup de mal en pis où on fait
beaucoup de choix l'extérieur beaucoup
de routes
on est encore beaucoup en montréal et
québec que ce moment c'est moitié moins
que font coincer ce fait que c'est tout
un défi mais il faut apprendre à le
faire il faut faire du sport le plus
souvent possible
ça va être vraiment ses valises déclare
athée c'est 12 alphand juste peu importe
des tracts bouger l'attractif le pis ça
aide énormément la concentration puis
2,7 et des objectifs qui dit
je demande c'est tout à ton honneur de
lever nos requêtes faites mais moi j'ai
des échéanciers mais un peu maniaque
mois ces deux ans avance toute beauté 2
ans avance
ouais deux ans d'avancé comme je sais où
je vais être dans deux amis mais je suis
vraiment comme je le savais que je serai
ici au jour mais pas ici aujourd'hui le
mais ce qu'elle est un voyage mais je
savais où j'allais être rendue je savais
qu est ce que j'allais faire de ma vie
où j'ai besoin d'avoir un projet
centrale qui m'occupe puis je me suis
donné des objectifs à 20 ans qui
aujourd'hui gère 27 puis j'ai fait
vraiment je me donne les objectifs par
cinq ans mon dieu c'était ma thèse de
doc c'était comme mon film que je sur
lequel j'aurai depuis trois ans mais
puis et bâle a eu d'autres projets qui
se sont greffés métier c'est de pas
détourner d'eux mêmes
sinon je suis déprimé piger comme faut
vraiment que je me trouve une discipline
et qui me couche je suis très discipliné
je me couche pas si star que ce jeu ne
soit pas beaucoup depuis que j'ai coupé
l'alcool puis j'ai vraiment plus de
concentration je suis beaucoup plus
heureuse je bois un peu mais suppose que
quand j'étais un peu plus jeune
excessive j'étais très excessive n'ont
pas été machin machin et y jetez pas
focus le jetez pas mentalement à l'air
khl qui à un moment donné quand ça je
vous le dis en fait quand arriva à la
maîtrise ou quoi que ce soit tu peux
punaisé nécessairement si tu fais comme
toi comment tu fais pour haïti c'est
finalement moi en fait
avant de partir à occupation double
quand j'ai appris j'ai appris que je
partais occupation 2 ma maîtrise en
création littéraire il ya une partie qui
est un qui sait eastick polanski
création puis je m'étais dit je veux
terminer la partie et c'est eastick
avant de partir que ça m'a pris
pendant deux mois puis je les fait vite
et bien j'ai vraiment me suis surpris
pendant deux mois je me levais un peu
comme tu décris je me j'avais juste à
faire je transige avait pas de travail
j'ai appuyé contre les éditions étiez je
t'ai fait que je me levais le matin
j'écrivais par un bon bloc de trois
heures je faisais des recherches visage
à la bibliothèque pour pour cette
particule monkey plus théorique de mon
mémoire puis après ça j'allais
m'entraîner je revenais chez nous je
faisais la même chose
puis presque je me couchais que j'ai
fait ça pendant le mois et demi je suis
pas ça avant de partir parce que je
savais qu'après c'est ça le brasser plus
puis quand je suis sorti comme de faire
il me restait ma partie création puis
première main
sur quoi la foi doit écrire et je fus de
dao ce que je pense que j'allais le
faire sur aude et finalement
c'est de trouver quelque chose de
pertinent dire de mon point de vue à
moitié ça viendra plus tard soit
peut-être que oui peut-être pas pour ma
maîtrise qu'il faudrait que je fasse le
jeu j'ai commencé une sur quelque chose
d'autre pays
dernièrement peut-être dans le dernier
mois j'ai commencéà à me lever pour
écrire le matin parce que sinon il ya un
million sont celles dans une autre pièce
que je m'assoie ici puis au que je
déconstruisent des patterns de refresh
aimons fidh facebook à chaque deux
minutes ou que je déconstruis certains
patrons pour me remettre à l'endroit où
ce que j'étais quand chez care de créer
vraiment mais si moi j'ai un truc
vraiment pratico pratique pour ceux que
j'utilise - c'est aussi parce que je
capable de décrocher des réseaux sociaux
mais la méthode pomodoro peut-être que
vous la connaissez
commente en italie 6 30 minutes que tu
te mets un timer le tout prend cinq
minutes de pause que tu sais absolument
rien 31e de travail cinq minutes de
pause c'est bon c'est vraiment bon parce
que tu te mets ton times un pit est
obligé d'être en mode avion vraiment
c'est vrai que les réseaux sociaux
affecte beaucoup notre concentration
salon se veut dire c'est fou c'est
dégueulasse même quand moi j'étais au
bac j'avais déjà facebook en fait
facebook est arrivé dans ma vie au
secondaire et je suis devenu
automatiquement accros qui j'ai vu ma
concentration aller n'importe où et
quand on gagne il faut se trouver cette
routine neuf sinon ça devient puis ça
prend cette discipline a aussi dans
l'écriture puis dans la concentration va
écrire de la marde
ouais c'est ça la marche à la fois parce
que tu es en sortant d'audi j'avais pas
écrit ça faisait quatre mois
pis tu sais quand j'ai recommencé à
écrire c'était pas bon bon ben j'ai
perdu la tête des entraînements et c'est
exact
c'était pas bon pis là je me disais je
te revois mon nom c'est de la marque
fait que j'écrivais papa en 2 millions
de centimes en exemple le je me suis dit
cheikh je veux finir mon mais man show à
écrire un premier jet complet après ça
je reprends ce je veux m'en aller dans
un chalet dans deux semaines je vais
leur écrire au complet avec eux rien
d'autre qu'une loge réservée à un point
mieux dire qu'il faut que je me force à
refaire je me force à mettre en mode
créatif sinon c'est le texan daudet
aussi se fait que tu aies pochette en
mode réaction après ce qui se passe si
cet acte arrive des propositions de ce
pip ce que je trouve intéressant ce que
tu sais tantôt c'est que 7 des objectifs
à long terme
c'est peut être dérogé souvent ligne
droite tandis qu'à défaut d'avoir des
bons dérape à acheter il faut tout va
quand même aller prévu et ouais mais
justement de ce phare une ligne d'essai
le plus possible pitié c'est parce que
quand tu es juste comme au gré du des
choses qui t'arrive puiser des idées ou
est-ce que levante emmène des plus tard
pour tourner et puis pourquoi pas
questionné sur j'en ai eu un ou deux
dérapages professé les cachets qu'un
petit frère
ouais c'est ce pis si c'est sans offense
mais c'était pas pour moi c'était pas là
ce que je devais faire à ce moment-là ou
du moins j'ai appris des choses mais
c'était pas ce que je m'étais donné
comme ligne directrice puis de trouver
l'adn son identité si tu le sais c'est
quoi ton identité donc envie d'aller
vers ce bingo m'étais-je à donner un
petit exemple années passées durant
occupation double justement vous étiez
peut-être au courant mais moi j'ai fait
une dénonciation pour agression sexuelle
nous on est ce c'est la grosse cagole
est sorti
ouais le conte est tombée on a fait j'en
est revenue dans l'actualité pour le
fait ils ont même mis au courant que je
passais cette année on s'est fait sur
des maisons dont on vous laisse on est
sortis nous en fait sortir des maisons
plus nous on dit là si vous sortez d'ici
est quelque chose que vous devez savoir
éric salvail et c'est fou ce sens parues
parce que lui avait un lien coude et il
existe un concept le concept de base
sont dits las vous devez savoir ça pis
ils ont dit c'est un des pires
qu'annoncées sera mon dieu ça tellement
est un chef d'oeuvre qu'est qu'on est
sorti six mois avant dallas aux dés mon
acteur préféré stevens p6 mon humeur est
préférée c'était louis siquet cam aussi
les deux camps avant d'aller au destin
cela viendra mais dans mes chutes je
fais j'en écoute il ya eu quelques
succès la révolution methi's l autre
bref j'avais croisé d'ailleurs j'ai du
temple à une émission on dira ce qu'on
voudra du canada je connais une qui
chronique ou si le puits je me rappelle
qui décolle je comprends pas ce qui
s'est exactement déconnecté de plus
quand tu reviens pleinement depuis six
semaines
bref tout ce que j'ai l'année passée
j'ai pris la décision dénoncée après je
pense ça fait deux ans que je pensais et
tout mais l'avait dénoncé
nommé dénoncé ouais exactement [ __ ] de
suivi la fin j'ai dénoncé apprend le
nommant métissé on s'entend que tu
lances passe comme ça ben quoi qu'il y
en a qui le font comme ça plus tard et
que c'est beaucoup de responsabilité
sociale si tu le fais attends toi à
vivre de quoi de gros pigeon je viens
encore les conséquences de ces
aujourd'hui qui sont positifs pour moi
c'est un bon choix mais sa meuf fait
déraper pendant au moins six mois
parce que après cette affaire le bail a
fallu que s'il ya eu tout le monde en
parle plus on a lancé les cars jaunes on
a fait plein d'affaires géant organisé
un show avec kate and ya justement qui
est anne et saint jean de je suis
indestructibles avec mélanie le mid qui
met conflit de l'an sexuelle en
organisant un espèce de gros show qui
m'a pris tellement d'énergie
puis j'ai été sur le carreau après son
non match com - roche plus capable que
j'ai pas arrêté d'octobre
d'octobre à mars ceux des foyers
m'arrive juste à voir quand je disais
c'est des bulles d'engagement le gie une
grosse bulle d'engagement mais intense
mourad hic comme aussi en 2012 quand je
peux si vous avez été impliqué dans
l'ouverture à vos universités
respectives mais moi ça ça m'a pris d'un
bon pied ce pauvre et que j'allais
passer à côté de l'histoire
je voulais prendre part à ce mouvement
le système je me sentais bien je t'ai
mobilisés mais j'ai passé six mois dans
rue j'ai fait d'autres n'étaient pas
capables de faire autre chose d'autre
pitt et j'aurais voulu être concentré je
n'aurai pas pu jeter pas concentrer sur
mes études j'ai concentré sur rien
lorsque je partais à paris mais pis si
cela n'est pas à ses yeux ce mouvement
ce mouvement là j'ai pas pu fallait que
j'y aille si c'était ça venait trop me
chercher donc je pense qu'on peut se
permettre des fois ce genre d'apartés
l'heure mais j'essaie quand même de
rester en ligne droite pas de me laisser
déroger mais parce que cegedim et honte
et je veux dire comme le film que je
prépare on a quand même un financement
de téléfilm canada et la sodec chili
comptes a rendues extrêmement
privilégiée de faire ce film je veux pas
que ça soit de la marde c'est mon
premier film je veux que ça soit
excellent mais je veux j'y rêve depuis
tellement d'années que je vais pas chier
ça pour une yedri ou quoi que ce soit je
vais tout donner pour faire ce projet là
mais ça prend une discipline ce pour
arriver à un moment de création se
dirait
aujourd'hui le jeu faire un album où
j'écris un livre je fais ma maîtrise
c'est un privilège qu'on a de la faire
quelques pas en même temps c'est pas
tout le monde qui peut le faire mais
faut se donner des moments de création
quitte à économiser de l'argent qui est
allé chercher une bourse mais moi je
trouve que faire trop en même temps si
on bat je pense que oui puisque nul
qu'on voit que j'ai six dernières années
il était décédé au début on se gâche un
peu partout pour le sec et prenons deux
projets maintenant l'aide front puis le
reste laisse de côté un petit peu pour
se concentrer sur vraiment qu'est ce
qu'on veut faire
ouais parce que tu peux en faire des
apparitions publiques tu pu faire payer
à faire tout le temps est ce que ça vaut
la peine qui est ce que tu as envie de
le faire est ce que tu sens mais là
dedans que je dirais c'est ce que vous
avez dû être mobilisés par toutes les
parties sans faute on a dit non
vous avez dit dans ce cas on a fait un
mort
parce que c'est à québec puis on voulait
aller voir nos amis mais moi j'étais
venu en photo c'est un choix
des forces étaient démesurées et comment
tout le monde venait prendre et celle fi
de tous bords tous côtés j'ai pas le
temps de parler aux que mes amis qui ont
regardé le dernier
tu vois si rapidement c'est un contexte
que certains auraient triplé sa tête
arrive le toute l'attention puis ces
malades qui n'ont laissé ça me convient
pas aux subtils c'est assez bête à ce
moment là c'est clair mais à voir la
tension toi non justement ça je le
savais avant d'aller en ce moment dans
la rue le monteur qu'à nice ils viennent
pas de voir qu'un qui sont chaudes mais
pour quelqu'un cholet qui reconnaît
qu'elle doit ramener j'avais vu georges
st-pierre tu le connais très bien oui
j'avais georges st-pierre dans un bar
puis mon ami c'était un after palin
natation qui mon avis bruno qui sera un
grand groupe lui était chaud un peu puis
georges st-pierre est avec des gros gras
coûte lui le genre jirga en fait un des
gros gars qui regardent georges chelon
qui fait dire à mon ami plus il ya des
groupes fait ouais c'est vrai que
j'aurais quand même musique
j'ai demandé à georges une faute ou aux
sels fille regarde d'abord on était
impressionné déjà c'est apprendre story
georges st-pierre fut un temps où est-ce
qu'au québec qui était moins connu qu'à
l'international ouais c'est ceci quand
même souvent québec je trouve que pour
reconnaître quelqu'un faut qu'il soit
reconnu à l'international pour qu'on
fasse avec mais oui ça marche je leur ai
compté mais pas tout le temps là ouais
mais ça je sais ce que c'est par ici et
beaucoup d'artistes qui fonctionne en
france puis un long et reconnaissent
céladon en parlait pas tant que ça avant
qu'il devienne gros en france
c'est la raison pour laquelle il était
là tout le monde en parle la première
fois que j aurais pas je demande c'est
puis je dirais qu'ils ont demandé de
changer ton accent en france comme un
pays si c'est ça fait ça faisait
longtemps qu'ils étaient avec oui
complètement mais moi je trouve ça un
peu moche je trouve que les médias sur
le rap sont un peu naïf ne sait comment
mon dieu la grosse affaire à des
nouveaux gars qui vient de battre le
record des beatles sur le nombre de
temps passé au billboard en haut le nom
de temps où les hommes de chansons ou
dans le tas de bois je sais pas le
métier c'est le record de tous les temps
sauf que les paysages changent et puis
la manière de consommer a changé puis à
l'époque tu pouvais pas avoir plus
qu'une tonne à la fois ou deux dans le
billboard puisque tu avais une pige à
radio maintenant la mort ne pas avoir
tout l'album billboard en avant mais
était sur ce fou comme l'attention
portée au rap sur ce super métier
oublions pas le cas même si mme ashton
n'oublions pas que guylaine tanguay chez
les gones n'ont jamais remporté au spam
appui respect pour la laddh du vent de
200 mille albums jeudi si le style qui
va un peu de baume au coeur
je pense qu'une reconnaissance
symbolique de durable mais ils vendent
pas beaucoup disent que non
c'est un public différent c'est un
public qui écoute en streaming c'est
fait que le public country c'est un
public qui achète des albums où j'ai
beaucoup plus âgés c'est le leur succès
se mesure pas de la même manière comme
deux frères comme comparer des pommes d
ornon exactement source à ce qu'on parle
juste pas mais le ya comme une espèce de
d'attention médiatique plombes à lauris
alors qu'on a vraiment méprise et ce
pendant des années je trouve qu'il ya
une petite hypocrisie là dessus on a
évité coriace soit il peut qu'inspirer
info j'écoute
on parlait de on parlait justement de
changer les dernières années mais moi je
pense que j'ai deux maxis et ça a quand
même marqué notre génération est en
première année
c'était en première de matic j'aimais
be2 mais j'aimais aussi gabrielle
destroismaisons et que je dis rapide
c'est une bonne chose mais dogmatique je
leur écoute cet ancien parce que j'écris
un roman qui se passe un peu dans ma
jeunesse à de l'essence et j'ai comme un
gothique tellement bon mais non j'ai pas
touché passe à côté un peu mais c'est à
vous cacher j'ai hâte que comment
c'était dans mon milieu
ttt un punk ou terrasses et à qui tu
parles arabes voulaient rien savoir je
découvre ce vraiment plus tard puis mais
c'était vraiment drôle comment y avait
une fracture là cet été 30 entier un
groupe ou l'autre je me suis dit qu'avec
ma vie chris ray messenger une fille que
je connaissais poppy et m
la question ce titre - ce qui est
touchée comme ça tu en feras pascal puis
ma soeur alexandra y écoutait chognard
non exécutées quand tu étais frères et
soeurs plus vieux que tu écoutes du
groupe punk c'est le premier album
connecter chez nous studio spring à moi
aussi j'aimais ce métier je me rappelle
que sts a volé pour le rappeler ces gens
sans pression autre que moi ça me
faisait pas de commentaire sur sans
pression puisque et comme je me sens pas
à l'aise mais j'aimerais quand même de
matic malgré tout même si je n'avais
aucune culture musicale sincèrement
j'aime et britney spears pis à s'arrêter
là puisque sinaï à l'erreur n'est ce pas
le cas mais bref ce samedi gosse en ce
moment puis j'aimerais faire un
auditorium et historien mais aussi la
couverture médiatique du pote le gitan
non si c'est démesuré le jeudi on a pas
on a parlé comme sa lettre la bogue de
l'an 2000 le veulent pas longtemps pis
ces genres de la journée que ça arrive
et c'est comme le dit apocalypse est
toujours sorti avec des gars qui fume
aident pas dieu qui je fume une fois de
temps en temps est sûr qu'on croit
d'ailleurs à mitsou et les âges avaient
fumé un joint qui m'ont coupé au montage
non mais si oui avez souhaité palace
mais peu mais moi je fumais pas
mais me soit voulait pas fumer soit on
est très alarmiste clac
sincèrement je comprends la part des
psychoses puisse comprendre ce mais je
sais pas je pense j'ai été élevé dans
une autre mes parents de parler de
drogue s'était ouvert d'esprit mais je
veux dire on m'expliquer les risques
avec ce tir auch pro qu'on infantilise
beaucoup c'est pourquoi votre position
là dessus mais moi ma position moi je
fais je consomme poche en poche j'ai
fumé passé seize fois de potes dans ma
vie j'en qui j'ai eu
j'ai eu l'expérience qu'ils étaient même
qui était très moyenne
baptisé moi ça m'intéresse pas vraiment
mais je prends pas conditions
mentalisation je pense que c'est une
bonne affaire
c'est juste
mieux comprendre que dans ce métier il
faut pas non plus penser que c'est la
fin du monde mais mais ça pouf
je crois on a parlé coriace je connais
des examens fermé parce qu'ils y en a
quatre et coriace que tu es à chaque
soin chaque nuit demande qui prend dans
l'urgence qui pense que son jésus mais
qui sont dans psychose maniaco spot et
l'alcool fait beaucoup de dommages aussi
leurs faiblesses ans c'est accepté ces
normes à la société taxe c'est très
hypocrite de des crises qu'ils portent
qu'un que l'alcool est plus dense très
hypocrite qui je trouve carrément dany
jeudi si on peut encadrer puis au moins
donner la chance à justement d'essayer
de faire autre chose que le marché noir
puis de voir ce qu'on a comme drogue
parce que moi je suis beaucoup plus dans
la légalisation général que dans la
criminalisation pis même par rapport à
en tout cas la procession se ranger mais
c'est juste trop qu'on infantilise
beaucoup mais en même temps quelques
faits des comportements de textes
commandes dont les avoirs points il va
avancer comportement là qui sont d'evian
est problématique que ce soit légalisée
ou non oui qui je trouve qu'on ne leur
propre facile sur le poteau québec moi
je voudrais juste dire que j'ai fait mon
examen rétrospectif ans fument un joint
mais une poche par jour là mesdames
concentrés en ce moment je fume pas ça
fait trois mois que les fumigènes sont
dépendants ont tu comprends mais sinon à
quoi ça quoi scellier dépenses la
couverture médiatique de campagne de
terreur contre la légalisation de thé ce
qui est drôle c'est que les orgues les
arguments on en parle comme si le monde
fumait pas des jeux
la dame qui vont aller acheter du pote
le légal il fume des je ne sais pas quoi
maintenant c'est les gars peut-être
canaux des curieux qui vont essayez le
sauf que ce monde le fûmes des jeux
akbar mieux by pas si le marché noir
je vois que des avantages mais je trouve
qu'on est une province quand même assez
conservatrice je veux dire quand même
voter pour l'acaa kg 73 députés je
trouve que sur le plan identitaire on
est assez conservateur je veux pas faire
des généralisations ni de québec bashing
mais je pense que on a un typhon judéo
chrétien puis il ya une opportunité
aussi financières qu'on pourrait prendre
qui n'est pas prise en ce moment est un
c'est une catastrophe de ce qui se passe
dans madame s
mario bros l'ontario je pense qu'à une
chose des galas soucis avec dog fourni
mais il ya quand même plus l'opportunité
je sais pas je pense qu'un petit pont
jetée aux chrétiens on a par dessus et
que j'étais rome et j'ai pas vraiment
analyser la question c'est mon ressenti
pour le moment mais je pense qu'on
devrait peu salée dans l'éducation pis
encore une fois j'ai vu tellement
d'articles sensationnaliste que je
comprends qu'on peut pas nuancé sur pie
souvent c'est des gens qui ne yo oui il
ya des difficultés tout qui ils me
disent opinion là-dessus mais je dire il
ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui vont
émettre les opinions sans connaître sans
être des consommateurs sans être dûment
si je dis regardez moi c'est une fumeuse
complètement fonctionnelle elle je dire
je suis pas en mauvaise santé je suis
pas des parents non plus
es6 et je pense qu'on peut nuancer tout
se met même temps qu'on je trouve ça
bien quand même l'âge de 21 ans
parce que c'est vrai que ça a fait que
les canadiens sachent pas content
nécessairement mais c'est que les 18-21
ils vont fumer car parfois qui vont
moins fumer je serai enfants y vivent
les fumées ont trouvé une autre manière
l'impression qu'il a marre de la fcdq
c'est vraiment d'éducation contrôle de
qualité et phi phi d'éducation effective
au lou pitt en apprend sur le cannabis
temps prenez différents je ne pense pas
en tout le monde apprend les différentes
sortes pu faire un dosage puis comment
bien j'aime ta facture
c'est vraiment positif qui me sens bien
ce qu'on disait tantôt de défectueux ou
toutes sortes de nouvelles qui ont pas
la même pertinence pour la même vigueur
sur internet ça devient comme toutes
égales oui si ça marche comme vraiment
chaud connaître cette idée mais plus par
rapport à l'alcool
je veux dire je sais pas si on double
vie tellement je sais pas vous avez fait
pour boire autant on sait qu'on boit pas
l'aspect accès à rien la semaine puis
arrive le parti qui parce que je suis
fait donner
c'est tellement plate classe même que tu
te donner quelque chose le samedi plus
des choses complètement tu me rappelles
quand j'ai emmené mes temps les caennais
de poppers long sprint quoi peut être
qu'on l'aimé tellement nos culottes pour
pâques ils les enlèvent ou qu'on puisse
les gardes et puis pas qu'on arrive
qu'on manque de tout
c'est juste parce qu'il y paraît si son
mollet ça faisait passer mieux afin
l'une des cités comme nos cadeaux les
amenait des grosses batailles microtech
inquiète les week-ends de production
python n'est pas et rien d'autre à faire
prenez aussi le qui se passe les
affaires les plus loufoques ou les plus
cette année les partis il y en a qui
font des fous des autres je suis
vraiment sur la précarité des nièces le
souci je suis pas quelqu'un qui tolère
bien à col que c'est l'occasion de vous
faire
l'orgie toutes vos filles toutes vos
papilles agressivité des fois ça sans
défense mais tout avait l'air de bien
tolérer l'alcool
je suis devant thibaut coulas votre
attention non je vais beaucoup c'est
juste que j'ai toujours été comme cela
je peux grimper le siffler quand je bois
je reste moi puis ma soeur ma soeur
quand tu bois tu es toi plus drôle est
que c'est tout moi quand je bois je sais
que j'aurai comme amener du ramadan
l'émission bois est vraiment des
salaires et habite à léry l'alcool aussi
non
ouais wallace qui semaine on a très bien
ce qui se passe c'est que quand
quelqu'un qu'elle arrive comme une ligne
qu'elle dépasse cette ligne là c'est
comme ça des cinq hommes de löw le cpie
le 6 mars et a dit chan règle et c'est
là que ça soit aussi oui oui oui c'est
le problème des blessures du passé le
soir quand tu es fier d'aider des crises
de larmes sous l'eau hamon mais vraiment
la colle au jour de l'année passée je
pense que j'ai toujours anxieuse
aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est pas ça m'a mis
dans des états pis là parce que c'est
drôle ça fait partie de mon roman
jeunesse parce que j'espère jeunesse
même dans ma jeunesse que j'explique
comment ça m'a angoissé quand j'étais
enfant le temps qu'il faisait ça fait
capoter aujourd'hui pas chaque jour de
l'an clavier si je suis vraiment su
rapidement pauvre l'année passée sérieux
amis lui disent jeter comme je vomissais
mettez un tel point ça lance le
chauffeur de taxi movida ah ouais je
pense qu'ils étaient proches et a
annoncé voici ma famille maintenant ce
sont des amis mais tiges avait pourtant
vu que ce dimanche matin comme
sincèrement le tutorat tellement mal
alcool vite une réalité mais c'est vrai
que le temps qui passe ça m'angoisse
beaucoup mes enfants très tôt le coma 4
5 achetés au magasin dans cinq ans oui
oui
souvent je ne devrais plus vu le plus
vieux plus jeune médian qui on veut
tendre je raconte ça dans mon roman
parce que je trouve ça un peu
surréaliste avec du recul que mon
passage de 4 à 5 ans pour moi c'est un
extrême coup de vieux que j'ai eu c'est
comme vraiment l'oeil le lot upro plus
jamais revenue dans quatre oui je me
rappelle très bien des fois je fais ce
genre d petit black out enfants comme
vraiment intense de comme je fermais les
yeux puis je méditais un peu puis jetée
comme j'allège on voit que je perdais
qu'en connaissant même pas mais comme
avec la réalité le temps qui s'était
vraiment comme existentialisme à la
ferme et à cinq ans a été vraiment ce
soit un gros coup de jus qui
mais avec du recul comme c'est tout à
fait pas normal non je suis vraiment
équilibré mais plus tard après ça j'ai
eu des grosses prises six de conscience
de la chance pour moi était vraiment une
espèce de révélateur de comme le besoin
de justement d'agir de créer une ci
dessous le temps qui passe mais c'était
très existentialiste le parce que les
enfants peuvent l'être s'il laisse aller
dans la voie que nous suivons le sont
les enfants sont très philosophe
beaucoup plus confuse excessivement et
puis on l'a on apprend le pull lettre ce
qui est triste c'est parce que des fois
qu'on questionne tron choisir d'arrêter
questionner ou deux mais les enfants une
curiosité pillon des réflexions support
philosophique mérité pour le temps qui
passe si je suis extrêmement
philosophique pourquoi pourquoi ça va
vite comme ça qu'est ce que tous ces
questionnements l'a souvent les atteint
avec le temps parce qu'on se bat
salariés mais c'est vrai qu'elle est en
contact avec l'enfant c'est hyper
stimulant pour pourquoi c'est comme ça
pour quoi
pourquoi je me questionnais vraiment je
n'arrivais pas à croire que moi je
t'aime moi dans mon cas ouais toi tu
vivais la même chose que moi dans ton
cas
c'est une autre personne qui le ramène
blot lkd t'acheter un enfant très jeune
j'avais conscience qui est moi j'avais
contrôle de moi mais j'ai pas le
contrôle de toi mais toi tu as le
contrôle de toi mais tu le vis comme moi
les yeux puis non c'est ça ça peut ça
passe après un prélèvement des vertiges
à repenser à ce la conscience de soi
mais si tout les philosophes sont
déprimés pire sauf que s'amplifier pour
sortir tous des prix mais non sont pas
tous des budgets des communes bah oui ça
va être cool jusqu'à souligner après la
cellule du commun qui s'est sentie moi
si je me pose cette question le comment
qui s'est senti quand il s'est suicidé
il parce qu'il n'ya pas lui qui suit
parce que
des contacts sont déjà prononcés plus
hauts plateaux parce que je trouve que
c'est vraiment humble parce que platon
est clairement une immense intellectuel
mais juste en scène secrète mais c'est
ce qu'il ya de ces réflexions l huile
dans le fond le socrate tout autant
platon que ça craque
mais c'est le oggi nouveau aujourd'hui
c'est très simple comme comme madoff
d'avoir fait les lancers mais peut-être
justement qui admettait qu'il ne savait
pas ce que ça coûte rien et great de sa
vie sa création il devait boire beaucoup
avec les jeunes qui auraient été
accusées à qui cette attaque est
rarissime et essai complet jugé que la
dette
c est ce qu il faut distinguer l'homme
de l'oeuvre c'est une enquête sur nos
questions sur cette question je serai
que entente à la vision de ce on parle
beaucoup de woody allen
why not the beast un croquis difficile
parce que c'est un cadeau une parole
contre une autre
souvent savoir métiers des cas comme
ceux pour new look chic et doit être si
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que masquer ce que
je peux encore écouter son spécial
netflix trouve ça drôle
c'est une bonne question c'est comment
ce conte comment est ce que je peux
encore consommé ça parce que je me
rappelle que son spécial les flics je
l'écouté au moins deux fois qu'il serait
gelé paraît que d'après y est drôle je
me rappelle que s'il est de qualité de
décrire des blacks
comment ces structures est ce juste j'ai
pas une grande fan du mot parce que on
les humoristes québécois sont venus
chercher très fan du mort américains
risque et j'allais découvert je sais pas
si je dire l'exemple qu'on donne tout le
temps si céline
qui était antisémite après sotchi eu
d'autres trous de cul qui en fait des
choses extraordinaires
alexandre dumas fils c'est le premier
anti féministe mais j'ai adoré la dame
aux camélias
est ce que je vais vous démontrer zir je
pense qu'il faut distinguer l'homme de
l'oeuf mais en même temps dans certains
cas de reconnaissance sociale actuelle
et il faut se garder une deuxième
surtout dans le coq dans le cas que
c'est des figures historiques qui se
mettront d'accord revisite avec lui
aujourd'hui sont un certain comportement
de 200 ans mais le sait ce que toutes
ces personnes avaient des comportements
produit la problématique le soc éclat le
dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui c'est
plus difficile
moi personnellement j'ai toujours mes
temps que j'admire quelqu'un j'admets
toujours une slice de quelqu'un voilà
j'ai toujours mouillé trophée de ce team
et on admire michael phelps jamais pas
michael phelps pour toutes les facettes
de mike offerte
j'admire son talent comme d'argent arty
qui j'ai toujours vu ce même petit
joujou touquet prix des idoles pris une
personne en idole prix des petites sly
de chacune des personnes que je trouve
intéressant pu me créer une espèce de
d'amal gamme de chose que j'admire chez
différents personnels c'est sûr tout
n'est pas noir ou blanc
c'est le très difficile de
compartimenter puis de paix de juger la
femme était exemple chez paquet 26 mois
c'était un de mes acteurs préférés dans
american beauty of the collection je
trouve que c'est un grand acteur
je reconnais encore sa valeur d'actif
par contre sa valeur du vin je trouve
moyenne qui est ce que j'ai envie de le
célébrer aujourd'hui non si j a célébré
dans un événement comme les oscars chaud
que l'oeil ya un malaise parce que y'a
leur contexte et sociale qui nous dit à
une tendance peut-être t on ces postes
je veux dire je sais pas où ça en est
dans les démarches et tout mais on veut
donner le bénéfice du doute que c'est
probablement qui agit mal si autant de
témoignages
mais si effectivement dans l'histoire si
je pense qu'on peut
je pense que ça serait un peu facile de
dire ben non l'oeuvre de quelqu'un on
veut juste les facile parce qu'il a agi
ou parce qu'ils avaient des
comportements étranges quoi que ce soit
et heidegger continuer à être lui même
s'il était nazi que sauver l'honneur
était antisémite
sa musique est belle sa musique est
extraordinaire si on peut pas leur nom
c'est par contre dans la célébration
actuel des choses il faut en tenir
compte
comme le fait qu'on a changé le terme
bien le nom jutra du prix restant
nettement j'ai pas vraiment suivi le
dossier
mais si la clinique ou du cinéma
considéré comme un malaise avec ce terme
là ben je respecte ce choix le mais par
contre je vais
l'humour c'est quelque chose parce que
l'humour ce jeudi tout une subtilité un
double sens dans l'humour puis on dirait
que c'est vrai que ça vient casser un
pull pailleté quand tu sais que legault
avait mais j'aime me spoil et en même
temps le monde sait qui tu peux une
manière aussi de prendre ses démons ya
des jobs de masturbation le lycée 6h
lobster roll si quelques réapparition
depuis qu'ils arrêtent et laissé pointer
dans des comédies club
je pense qu'il est allé lui à
l'improviste dans même puis faire un
numéro 2 ouais c'est dur aurait en fait
parce que c'est des soieries que tu vois
le peu qu'il fasse pointe et taxes et ja
peut être pas les armes étaient les
propriétaires du club dix c'était pas
d'accord je peux te lever et quitter
pigeons je peux même laissé tomber le
genre ça ne me dérange pas mais lui il a
fait un trouble de dépendance
d'ajustement des sécheuses et d'enfoncer
que lui et ont évité définition chambre
d'hôtel plici les avec un jeu au pied
levé de funk amman et leur demander
genre tu peux te masturber devant vous
autres qui le souvent les filles de prix
de copiste est un humoriste et
gaullistes historiques fait des blagues
tout le temps affecté des fois tu peux
passer je pense que sercel a répondu oui
mais pas sans que steve jobs is malefoy
messadié sparaco
il était accompagné leur pillay est un
peu mais bien peu comme dans le chemin
de votre stand et a demandé par francis
paraît cohérent c'est sûr que c'est un
comportement problématique qui son
comportement qui est qui qui qui pas
correct
ça serait vraiment perd encore s'il
avait juste sauté dessus
strelok du haut nil mais c'est quand
même toutes les problématiques mais un
os qu est ce qui peut l'être ce que
c'est légitime qu'ils reviennent refaire
de l'humour apprécié en fait je peux pas
empêcher cette colonne après ce le monde
va décider montréjeau est ce que
j'achète un billet pour ce ça marche à
son truc
non mais où apparemment il y ades de
front se fait pas comme sextape haut et
comme son show où ses blagues mais yahia
demi où son sort le jeu parce qu'ils
aient admis qu'ils avaient même j'ai
trouvé que sa réponse était était quand
même si c'est toujours cela ça prend le
temps la réponse puis sincèrement il y
avait l'art comme on est là dans pi et
j'ai comme l'impression que ces gars là
vraiment comme un trouble fonctions mais
personne on pique ses traits permettent
dogmatique mais je n'ai pas dit que je
m'excuse pas bien sauf qu'ici un
problème de dépendance et quelque chose
ouais c'est clair mais lui je pense
qu'il ya vraiment comme un fait exprès
mais si c'est sûr que pour par exemple
luiz qui je connais pas celle que je
peux pas trop commenter mais je pense
que en ce moment système de justice et
hydro le mans fait et c'est difficile
d'incriminer quelqu'un pour toutes
sortes de raisons très pratico pratiques
qui sont des technicalités qu'on rentre
pas là dedans mais n'est pas une
complexité d'un système de justice qui
font en sorte et c'est difficile
d'incriminer quelqu'un présomption
d'innocence c'est bien mais ça aussi un
revers c'est comme en droit criminel
faut que soient condamnés hors de tout
doute raisonnable mais ça fait en sorte
que ben du monde qui sont pas
nécessairement condamné alors qu'ils
devraient l'être
moi je crois à la justice et je crois au
pardon aussi après avoir comme vécu sa
peine et ses terrains donc je me disais
il ya des gens qui
ce qu'ils vont faire comme si de rien
c'est comme si rien ne s'était passé
qu'ils vont vivre finalement très bien
sans avons vécu ce processus dont moi
j'ai un petit malaise site à béjart
mahrez en fait si tu as commis un geste
incriminant bien un geste de domination
pic qui oppose justice qui a été fait
c'est dans ce sens là mais si on vient à
la question de est ce qu on doit
distinguer la personne de l'oeuvre je
pense que sincèrement oui mais en même
temps si ton oeuvre réitère des rapports
de domination que ou quoi que ce soit ou
la valorise oula glamourise logis avec
ses pairs tant que le boutiquier c'est
plutôt l'inversé plutôt il fait il fait
le constat l'apologie des commentaires
médecin yade metz et arles
mais ces sacs mousse et louis xi qui
gémit sa réponse parce que j'en ai vu
plusieurs des réponses agressant des
services ' puis j'ai trouvé qu'ils
avaient une nana et et puis une
vulnérabilité qui était l'hôte et ça n'a
pas été la réponse officielle de tir aux
en quoi que ce soit mais c'est pas un
gem excuse de relations publiques que
j'ai senti un vrai j'aime excuse c'est
quand une réponse de la part de familles
deux filles pie qui gênait un pic yves
pas fier de lui c'est une réponse d'un
coup comme ça voici mon agresseur
m'avait dit hey je m'excuse je m'excuse
de ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait du tort qu'acheter commis je
leur ai pardonné
on serait pas rendue aujourd'hui c'est
le site une justice te détester porté
plainte à la police
ouais mais je peux pas aller plus loin
dans la discussion vaut mieux qu'elle
pendant paris
[Musique]
non c'est donc ce que je peux dire par
contre c'est que si cette personne là
avait simplement dit je pense que depuis
j'ai un problème j'ai un problème de
comportement je tente de le régler de
leurs accepté film aussi c'est important
pour moi se passe car on dénie c'est la
ville s'est pas noir ou blanc
dès le 6 il ya tout est dans la nuance
puis moi je pense qu'on une erreur est
humaine
puis à un moment donné un comportement
de domination quelconque une violence
des fois ça s'explique par tout un
bagage de vie qui je pense qu'il ya je
crois pas que ça c'est nécessairement in
et je pense que c'est acquis on élit ce
qu'écrit un buste et on le voit en
prison je veux dire les hommes qu'à buzz
qui s'amusent entre eux et souvent eu
des cas aussi de céder fois de
pédophilie et qui tire aussi si loin la
violence et intergénérationnelle on en
parle aussi avec nous toute la violence
intergénérationnel des pensionnats chez
les autochtones tillet tout
alors faut je pense qu'il faut sortir de
la simple c'est de la simple c'est de
voir ce noir ou blanc et toute une
nuance mais par contre moi je crois aux
excuses et au pardon
personnellement comme si j'avais
agresser quelqu'un je veux voyons donc
et il faut s'excuser il faut sauver le
site et un problème là de sentimental
soi que ce soit prend acte des excuses
doigt mais j'ai vu beaucoup de gens qui
étaient des abuseurs en général des
narcissiques qui admettait partant
jamais dans leur fille puisque je trouve
ça pas je sais ce que je pense que le
pardon peut exister je pense que je
pense que si on peut s'améliorer dans la
vie c'est le fun d'entendre un discours
nuancé comme ceux surtout quelqu'un qui
a vécu ce que tu as vécu
parce que le problème en fait c'est
pourquoi un abuseur ça va sortir puis
voir des gens qui vont défendre sa cause
bizarre et pas un amuseur 100% du temps
je sais pas si je parlais de sardanapale
cassent tout sur le dos par les très
bonnes amies peut être un bon voisin qui
presse près de sa personne
quand on a besoin des chirac parce qu'il
traduit si c'est une situation
inimaginable que la mise à pied de la
croix qui connaît autre chose cette
personne le cursus parce que quelqu'un
se sont animées diop est la seule chose
que tu connais d'une personne si café
dessus tout pour toutes les autres
éléments pour nuancer ton idée même si
même si c'est pas excusable t je n'ai
pas ici excuses et puis aussi si on
connaît tout
on connaît tout des gens qui ont été
victimes d'agressions autour de nous on
sait que c'est une femme se bat sur
trois vont se retrouvent mais sait on si
on sait sur quatre mais je le certain
qu'il ya trop de femmes
et à y rester pour qu'on connaisse pas
d'agresser puis coupet aucun d'eux
comment est ce que je veux dire mais ici
comme les hommes autour de nous qui sont
des bonnes personnes mais qui font des
choses aurait été ou des erreurs ou qui
sont mal informés si je prends juste mon
cheminement là dedans
suis je suis pas conscientiser je suis
pas informé chevaux la même personne que
j'étais le 10 ans et quand j'étais un
ado secondaire est exact que c'était mon
ami de filles de caunes c'est exact
c'est ce que j'ai appris énormément
parce que je m'informe parce que je vais
m'améliorer
parce que je veux est une bonne personne
c'est pis c'est ce puits et je pense que
ça passe beaucoup par l'éducation
paris des gueilles des filles pittis de
d'expliquer comme les rapports de ce
manga lecteur puis d'essayer de parler
des tabous outils jeu quant à une fille
qui se lit mort devant toi pic tu
couches avec figures et gollum
enterrement mais il risque d'avoir des
conséquences négatives pour la suite peu
importe c'est quoi consiste ce juste
l'expliqué j'ai l'impression que c'est
important puis en ce moment j'étais en
contact après avec des écoles pig les
certaines directions qui veulent pas
parler de ces enfants pauvres et nos
cours d'éducation sexuelle moi ce que je
me souviens c'est notre prof sylvie qui
met ça tape qui manque aux opticiens les
jeunes comme ce qu'on fait ce qui nous
raconte qu'elle ait eu un orgasme
ouais mais c'est plate mais c'est ce qui
m'est restée six qui nous est restée
pisser contre billet on parle de en
parle de mts aux velléités est un peu et
on se fait remettre un cordon à tout
prix
jamais entendu le mot consentement j'ai
jamais entendu une seconde a jamais
entendu un mot love qui sait ce qu'est
ce qu'être espino reçue le 2 semaines
coriace tpiy t
ski coriace parce qu'il n'est pas
nécessairement toujours prêché par
l'exemple dans son comportement pareil
avoir un gars comme lui que j'admire
qu'un château secondaire qui viennent
parler de ce google
un glock un modèle un mode de jeunes qui
vit qui connaissez quelqu'un que ces
soupes qui viennent quand on tirer de ce
qui s'est passé avant je me suis fait
parler de sexualité quand j'étais jeune
c'était comme toujours malin il y avait
aussi ça avait aucun rapport avec la
réalité été dans aucun moment donné tu
arrives dans la vraie vie pitt et comme
c'est pas quoi faire tu sais pas ce qui
est normal qui prônera s'est passé quoi
leur relation si elle ne sait pas que
des stands je parle comme ça c'est
peut-être qu'un risque à un moment donné
ça va déraper plaucheur de la sexualité
en général une relation saine goffi et
ça fait pas parler comme ça s'il parlait
de relations points est-ce que tu y la
jalousie juste la jalousie je veux dire
que ce soit fille ou guns rassure texte
ici c'est quoi pip que si la fille
jalouse il jaloux le jeu y'a pas de sexe
là dessus mais tient une relation
malsaine point c'est quoi moi j'aurais
aimé ça me faire dire davos comme ok
c'est il risque d'avoir sur ton parcours
des gens moins gentil dans un tel
contexte tel contexte puis peut-être
faire attention à certaines choses
publie pas de respecter la rampe ici des
titres des éléments comme des bagatelle
de deux trucs que tu le sais pop et je
trouve ça pas de mettre un peu la tête
dans le sable a tué en même temps ses
sources c'est aux parents faire ce goût
d'ailleurs en ontario ils ont régressé
par rapport aux cours d'éducation
sexuelle
ils sont retournés aux années 90 ils y
ont plus droit de parler de consentement
sexuel via une ligne de dénonciation
pour ceux et celles qui oserait parler
de consentement c'est dégueulasse
sincèrement ça fait pas cesser de parler
que ce soit à bout ça je pense qu'ils
les parents qui pensent que d'avoir
réfréner les ardeurs des jeunes ça fait
poste à fait le contraire
ouais ça fait qu'ils font mal et c'est
on le sait qu'au secondaire si le quai
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes vont avoir
leur première expérience sexuelle dit
ses parts d'en parler c'est une bonne
expérience sexuelle c'est comme une
fille
j'ai une musique ski
qui c'est qui va compter que sa première
expérience et avec son team titan
secondaire qui s'attendait pas trop mais
lui ça a été en dépit des jeunes de 16
ans 15 16 ans et bourru testostérone ça
aux pillages
c'est sa première expérience a été je
veux pas trop me dis ok mais là on y
voit paré pigot ça arrive plus souvent
qu'on pense que c'est triste c'est
vraiment très spis everett et ont
détruit ronde des remparts et moi
j'avais un poste est qu une agression
sexuelle à 10,71 quand je me suis fait
agresser jamais même post est ce si je
le savais pas que je me dis mon dieu
c'est moi qui est coupable m'ont dit que
si j'ai fait moi je suis là dans cette
circonstance le thé c'est comme mais non
ce mois ci un abus de pouvoir et une
agression sexuelle machin pitt et aux
docks dans des campagnes de
sensibilisation très infantilisante any
other side en parler ouvertement
sérieusement et de ne pas avoir pas d'en
parler parce que là on se retrouve aussi
avec les réalités numérique c'est ça
c'est fou le ce qui se passe si j'osais
avec tous confirment on supprime tout le
temps je veux dire film est un acte
sexuel qu'on diffuse après ça des
conséquences énormes non sur la le
dénigrement de la personne pense surtout
tu peux avoir enfin une culpabilité de
possession distribution juvénile
s'il ya peine à faire la queue je pense
pas que tout le monde est au courant
notre sol en 13 14 ans le jeudi 2
semaines ce quelqu'un à québec je me
secoue son nom dont il filmait des
mineurs puis au delà dates cet été comme
le chat qui fume qu'ils partagent à ses
amis plus les amis québec l'histoire de
sam bird et pas mal oui c'est ça c'est
une grosse histoire fille qui quitte son
histoire
d'ignorance sais pas comment j'ai pas
trop suivi dont ces normes et icc des
petits gueugnon qui ont réussi à
convaincre des défis je pense d'envoyer
des photos de nu humains des victimes et
ont fait qu'ils ont partagés alors jones
a fait le tour de l'école pilote à sa
sortie les gosses en fait suspendre la
grosse question c'est est-ce que tu es
renvoi est ce qu'ils étaient qu'est-ce
qu'on fait que ces jeunes lot c'est
parce qu'au fond qui soit à ken
puisqu'une punition faut qu'à une
punition il faut et surtout qui a
énormément d'éducation aucune indication
qui sait parler exactement mais dans mon
film que je prépare sur les supports
violences faites aux femmes
on a un cas qui est celui du mérite et
apparition qui est une jeune canadienne
de nouvelle écosse qui l écoutent pas
été arrosée du vendredi soir avec 15 ans
à boire piller 3go kiaka violent qui est
monsieur sait qui est le vidéo a été
diffusée dans toute l'école
évidemment eu de l'intimidation et de la
cyberintimidation après puis après ça
allait déménager plus vidéo encore été à
circuler à nouveau venu aucune
intervention de l'école c'était comme si
de rien n'était et au final après avoir
fait deux trois écoles à ces suicides et
tu dis c'est dramatique comme l'histoire
glenn carling son père justement est
donné conférence sur la question sur le
consentement qui justement l'ayant temps
l'ontario puis le i ce fait censurer
donc il ne peut plus parler puis fins de
prévention lui a perdu sa fille la danse
quand même horrible dont il faut pop
je pense que ça peut être très très gros
l'impact de ça on a aussi notre une
jeune fille qui s'appelle clara houde
qui a vécu ce que notre âge bien quitte
à bruges jeune mais qui a vécu ça dans
les années
au début le des réseaux sociaux elle a
vécu un cas similaire ou à camarès
écoute ça vraiment affecter sa vie
négativement le seul à le violer alors
vraiment eu des troubles estime de soi
après à sentais vraiment comme la marde
l'oeil des difficultés d'apprentissage
relier directement asus comme l'a dit
c'est que c'est comme si c'est un viol
collectif
elle à se retrouver après le lendemain
avec des photos d'elle
dans toute l'école c'est ça on sait
quand on est ado peut être méchant mais
on peut être très méchant je connais
colline soi même aussi sûrement tarbais
lévis jean vigo est convaincu notre
gauche thomas qui se faisait passer pour
une fille crauste one a même atteint
exactement si répandue la non créés
pendu quand même c'est dramatique
ce ça passe par l'éducation garde de
voir ce que ça va donner cours
d'éducation sexuelle
en tout cas il est animé par le docteur
à bonbons pu parler plus mon dock
celles ci seraient les discours
antiféministe en ligne des commentaires
annuler les commentaires haineux je
t'assure
ouais j'en ai reçu ben j'en reçois
régulièrement mais pas régulièrement
mais comme n'importe quel féministes qui
s'exprime en ligne j'en reçois le pic de
tout ce que tu as fait ton ferme en 2012
non je dirais que ça savary 2004 n'ont
pas tant que tu sais plus quand je
prends des positions un petit peu plus
radical sur internet genre auront donné
j'ai dit que denys arcand jeu tout et
qui dérape et en traitant les féministes
de commun qu'ils disaient d'hystérique
l'aïe avait dit ça tout le monde en
parle j'ai juste fait un petit
commentaire sur facebook je trouve ça
dommage que je trouvais ça dommage parce
que chez comme moyon les mouvements
sociaux puisqu'on peut les valoriser
puisqu'on part était de comme toujours
insulter les féministes ou les dénigrer
parce que se pose toute façon parce que
c'est comme si c'est un bloc à la pensée
unique le féminisme c'est de planter sa
promenade qui tu vis quand il parle de
type web exactement pourquoi les
féministes ray tout hystérique le c'est
ridicule vraiment pitié j'ai juste dix
ans arrive des fois un peu plus de
nuances
vraiment c'est rien écrire des
commentaires à people
parce que j'ai atteint denys arcand je
veux dire j'ai rien j'ai rien dit
violent je veux dire à la limite c'est
une réponse qui se veut moins violente
que ce qu'il a dit mais vraiment rien la
petite chérie compte denis arcand j
contre le commentaire que fait puis
vraiment des gros commentaires mais
sincèrement de faire une thèse sur les
discours antiféministe sur les
commentaires un nuage réalise piste est
pas une partie de plaisir le monde
analyse de données j'ai fait une analyse
de discours j'ai répertorié trois quatre
mille commentaires 1h10 féministe que
j'ai lu
dégueulasse et verra marché pas pourquoi
j'ai besoin mais bon j'ai fait j'ai bon
ça y est
et il je le prends tellement plus
personnel je ferais manger c'est rare
qu'une attaque
non vraiment on s'habitue dans le fond
c'est sûr que ça fait six mois que ça
fait comment cet été les plus vraiment
tu prend même plus au début tu prends la
peine de tout d'essayer de leur répondit
je prends le péno ça me fait rire c'est
pas tout le monde crie ça si ça fait
quand même un bout si j'ai quand même
dans l'oeil du public au monde il faut
que j'accepte qu'il veut cancer 2 à dax
qui est réalité ce nouveau fléau de nos
sociétés exactement mais en même temps
si je dis moi ça m'empêche pas de vivre
mais par contre j'aime pas qu'on attaque
des filles qui on peut demander rieti
qui ça ça me fait chier comme entité
mais avec mon coeur mon henry un moment
donné un lieu qui mérite la france les
français n'ont même si tu y as well as
botoxée dans dix ans tu vas voir l'art
dans batman le joker dans batman
si c'est comme les a clairement dit en
gros nichons savez comme je n'ai pas de
chirurgie esthétique et jeu dont je n'ai
pas la joker mais ça me faisait quand
même si vraiment henry les plus absurdes
séquences et méchant mais absurde c'est
plus drôle qui quand c'est méchant mais
que sa frappe proches des quelque chose
qui m'a fait plus c'est quand même bon
dernièrement j'ai eu honte j'ai fait une
prise de position sur un individu qui
est un photographe qui avaient
énormément allégations d'agressions
sexuelles que j que j'ai vu que je
dirais plein d'éléments qui sont
probables qu'il démontre qu'il ya des
comportements traître vraiment
problématique
ouais si c'est un métier je dire que le
système de justice considérant ce qui
lie je ne pense pas qu'il y aura de
plaintes émises mais l'espace que moi
quand ça fait comme vin une box que je
reçois puis comme dit il à ses
comportements lors qu'on me montrent des
disques une capsule qui ont pas été
partagée quand on me dit à des jeunes de
14 15 ans qui sont eux qui la donne je
donne donc c'est le bénéfice du doute et
je me dois d'intervenir pour dire
j'entends ces affaires le jeu ray je
suis solide
avec ces gens là pis bref et là j'ai
reçu des commentaires assez sur un peu
plus violentes et des gens qui sont
menacés d une voix comme une menace en
maudit été parce que le jeter un peu la
justicière qui est main propre aux pies
puis c'est ça qu'on sent menacé certains
se sentent menacés se donne le droit
donc de m'insulter
mais sincèrement j'ai une carapace puis
ce synode à faire que j'aimerais qu'on
puisse expliquer aux plus jeunes gars
comme fils cette adversité qui va
arriver dans la vie des commandes compte
qu'on fait pour gérer ça parce que comme
femme qui va recevoir des insultes qui
sont différentes que c'était un gars
puissent itv gunz va recevoir des
insultes qui sont différentes parce que
tvgl si tu es un joueur de hockey tu vas
te faire insulter différemment les
femmes çà çà çà çà çà donne comporte
beaucoup d'attention à notre sexualité
puis à notre physique lice avec les
éléments qui vont revenir beaucoup dans
les insultes qu'on va nous sexualisé est
mal baisées aubin a baisé avec pour
arriver là où titre tout à fait que je
suis comme vraiment ça aucun rapport et
ici souvent il ya aussi un dénigrement
intellectuelle totale qui vient avec ce
métier ça dépend dans quel milieu et
puis quelle posture public tu occupes ce
jeu m'a raconté sophie bessis et aux
gains les attaques que vous allez
recevoir t je pense qu'il faut apprendre
à vivre avec malheureusement parce
qu'elles vont être là c'est ce la
réalité d'être une femme sur le web en
2000 puis le plus que d'être en public
mais moi j'avais de mon documentaire
réalise qu'il ya plein filles qui ont
rien demander puisque ont attaqué
solidement pis vraiment intensément donc
devoir finalement piste un peu seule
féminine c'est de dire qu'il ya un
système social qui est plus haut que
nous picchi qui ne rien avoir avec notre
individualité
c'est plus un contexte donc moi je
prends plus personnel c'est l'enfer
est-ce que ça m'a affecté longtemps oui
ça va affecter je me suis beaucoup posé
de questions pendant longtemps j'étais
comme on dit est ce que je devrais juste
me taire est ce que je mets ça serait
juste leur donner finalement raison puis
j'ai une liberté d'expression puis je
vais je vais la prendre ma liberté de
parole
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont là tulle
devant les radios on libère des bas
aussi
voici sa mais voilà donc jeu pour la
thèse de doc ça a été difficile mais je
suis content de l'avoir fait parce que
ça m'a permis de prendre du recul sur
tous ceux et de me dire que le web c'est
vous enfin web c'est vraiment
extrêmement violente puis de essayer de
comprendre pourquoi c'est là mais moi
mais pourquoi ces violents mais qui
s'était dans le fond comment quelqu'un
dans révolu ce mois ci que l'on
questionne parce que le phénomène est
trop répandue pour ce soit juste une
petite gagne de koh lanta
oui il y en a trop fait qu'ici c'est la
grand-mère de quelqu'un qui connaît ses
deux cousines d'art et essai sa demande
normale sans tête comme contretemps tout
d'un bon monde autrement mais qui est
née sur internet tient dans une bulle ce
pauvre cookies mais je pense qu'il ya
plein d'éléments méthyle le web
d'abord été fondée dans un espoir un
idéal utopique d'horizontalité un peu
libertaire de dire à qui tout le monde
est égal pour nos meilleurs puis d'un
studio qui nuit exactement mais c'est
sur la base du web quelques passes c'est
de dire on va aller au delà de justement
des plates formes traditionnelles de
communication puis tout le monde va
avoir la liberté de parole puis ça va
être un échange collaboratif était un
peu à l'image de wikipedia et cetera on
vote on va créer nos savoirs on va
partager mon savoir et que ça donne et
les spas belles choses notamment le
mouvement féministe pris une ampleur
certaine et plein mouvement sociaux
grâce à ça parce que c'est un outil
extraordinaire de mobilisation de
partage etc
mais à travers tout seul comme eu un
revirement dans les dernières années où
on s'est rendu compte que finalement
certaines paroles et prix mais plus que
d'autres c'est à dire que il ya par
exemple bon jeu quand même nuancé mais
des des idéologies dominantes
par exemple celle du racisme c'est du
sexy sushi qui qui ont eu finalement pu
ce droit parole à travers tout ça parce
que ya des mécanismes d'intimidation de
violence qui sont ici pour faire valoir
la parole donc là on a vu que finalement
cet idéal là est un échec total et qu'
on était finalement dans un far web un
far west un oeil pour oeil dent pour
dent vu que la discussion était est
complètement
j'irai manque de civilité là c'est
l'espèce d'iliad utopique il ya échoué
disque on se rend compte c'est justement
ce cycle le web permet à la fois un
espèce de sentiment d'impunité en
psychologie des mondes donc tonnes sur
ton ordi 200 salles aux conséquences a
aucune conséquence donc impunité des
utilisateurs campés sur leurs aucune
conséquence les réseaux sociaux ne prend
plus de responsabilités les états ne
prennent pas leurs responsabilités à moi
qui ait vraiment une menace claire de
mort donc moi si je dis à pénélope
mcquade et une grosse vache m'excuse
mais il ya peu d'un c'est un pas
peut-être des gens qui vont peser moins
mais sauf que d'être derrière un écran
ça c'est un générateur d'agressivité la
ligne c'est la menace de mort la menace
de mars et se situe justement la liberté
d'expression c'est les policiers
prennent ça au sérieux des vraies
menaces de mort mais à côté de ça donc
type pourquoi ça rend si agressif ou
pourquoi c'est si violent le web c'est
que je crois aussi que le web est un un
reflet ou un amplificateur des violences
qui existent puis qu'on pensait qu'il
existait pas osé moi je pensais plus que
ça existait dans leurs assistants que ce
qu'on était allé aipis met sexy sexy
dans la musique qui de certains
regroupements qui avait pas la parole
comme par exemple l'insee est loué des
regroupements d'extrême droite qui avait
pas la parole qui sont aussi violents
par nature dans leur rhétorique qui ont
une parole sur le web et blogs qui se
créent des réseaux des forums etc cette
erreur et le qui ont une validation par
les pas parce qu'il y aura enfin une
parole il avait ces sas pas pour rien
que donald trump il est qu elles ont une
voix comme tsc pour ceux et celles qui
n'ont pas suivi ça c'est entre que
toutes les pizzas gates est en fait un
regroupement des sceptiques qui pensent
que les obama
elles sont ancrées dans un réseau de
pédophilie des démocrates et hillary
clinton et dans un réseau de pédophilie
clairement un peu dans le job cl mais si
c'est il ya tout un courant encore une
fois de figues news qui est de droite
d'extrême droite qui répand du pic et
enfin une parole sur le web
et donc ils se permettent de parler puis
d'avoir une parole désinhibé est ici une
parole qui qui violentent parce que elle
se sent menacée
c'est ainsi beaucoup sur la menace des
privilèges donc tout ce contexte là je
comprends pourquoi
mais le web permet ça si on encadre est
mieux un peu les propos haineux si je
pense ça ira mieux dans la société
l'allemagne a fait des gestes concrets
de mémoire zuckerberg facebook on ça
c'est payant la haine en ligne dit quand
richard martineau fait des statues de
marbre sur les musulmans qu'elle peut
supporter je sais c'est qu'il puisse
partager ses toiles article nuances et
c'est une inclinaison s'apaisaient pas
mais si vraiment c'est que le clic bête
aussi à merde c'est la vérité et la
vérité
exactement mon l'écoutent pas la vérité
on n'écoute pas les nuances on n'écoute
pas les intellectuels on n'écoute pas
les nuancer ce qu'on aime c'est le show
le spectacle est chez terreur franck
richard martineau pourquoi ça marche
autant c'est que c'est qui
très intense piller très radicaux la
date donc il peut nuancer je m'excuse
mais c'est un peu ce que c'est pis ça
tout un effet de giresse d'anti fication
peut-être qu'on aurait eu civile parce
que tu mets ton mot je te coupe metton
je te croyais - ainsi que le web puis
richard martineau réussir on le verrait
plus nuancé c'est parce que des fois
aussi c'est tout à la porte du clic bête
ou si les choses qui leur contexte ou d
un billet c'est souvent tu voudrais se
met à penser mettre que l'expriment pas
au complet j'espère oui pis c'est vrai
que tu as raison les réseaux sociaux
comme structure comme ca mène pas la
nuance joseph située à g
c'est quoi le cd photos est premièrement
il ya un
il ya une limite de temps de parler de
droit de parole de jeudi les caractères
sont quand même limité deuxièmement si
tu écris un poste nuance il ya personne
qui personne du toupet aujourd'hui je
lisais un article intéressant qui disait
comment certaines féministes
utilisez le
la rhétorique un peu de séduction dans
notamment les photographies dans les
partages acquéreur pour passer certains
messages
mais je trouvais ça comme intéressant
parce que c'était pas dans le jugement
quoi que ce soit ça constate est ce que
certes il faut utiliser les codes les
codes de communication ces réseaux
sociaux moi de toute façon je parle même
plus sur facebook parce que j'ai
honnêtement il put sur facebook
bon c'est bon fils zuma 2g des trolls
anti féministe qui viennent souvent mais
pas surpris par un schiphol le journal
de montréal ou quoi que ce soit pour
faire du québec pour montrer que je suis
tombé mais chantepie radical justement
donc j'ai plus envie de m'exprimer sur
facebook mais je m'exprime sur instagram
kimi sujets sont très limités donc je
pense que les réseaux sociaux amène la
nuance
on va terminer bientôt parce que nous on
compare même c'est passionnant bah oui
du match mais j'ai l'impression que
peut-être c'est l'effet que c'est quand
même un nouveau dans nos vies paraît
tout de même ça fait quelques années que
ça existe c'est juste dans l'histoire
d'humanité c'est direction si on parlait
de faire là dessus mais tu sais on
parlait de platon dans tout ça crappy
une des images les plus fortes pluies
les plus valables qu il est plus
important car augmenter c'est
l'allégorie de la caverne c'est pis
à 20 khz et les réseaux sociaux arrivent
mais premièrement on est tous dans la
caverne si on n'en sort jamais vraiment
mais certains sont plus dit que d'autres
c'est plus enfoncé qui la réalité qu'on
voit c'est juste un reflet dhombres
lointaine ces deux pôles copie la
réalité qu'on essaie de comprendre dès
qu'on pense que senna triel tes pieds
qui bref le j'ai l'impression que
l'internet
forcée mais thompson cavernes justement
peut-être pas vu le soleil pendant des
années si typique le sol est ce votre
format là nestea aux yeux avec le
continent
dans cette caverne toute ta vie piqué
l'internet de confronter des choses qui
sont le qui existe et que tu avais
jamais eu dans ton quotidien une team et
on devine qu'elle porte
tout ce que tu te rendes soul et noir
s'est dit fausseté ou si les choses
méchantes pour toi c'est ça la réalité
pourrait questionner plus loin je n'ai
jamais été confrontée se trouve que le
l'internet comprendre à titre de
nouvelle fois que tu avais jamais pensé
qui existait ou banquette comprenait mal
tu connaissais mal à clôturer à j 1
à ce qu'il pense être le gros bon sens
mais ce qui est à côté de la track
complètement parce que c'est tout ce que
tu fais ta caverne c'est vraiment
différente dans la caverne c puis je
prends l'exemple et les bonhommes qui
est où la madame qui insultent berlinois
relais et peña même avis pas la même
réalité cuba lannoy tiens c'est drôle
parce que ça me fait réfléchir même que
ces gens le comprennent pas nos réalités
mais parfois peut-être qu'on comprend
pas la réalité non plus même si ils ont
décidé des propos qui sont gracieusement
heures
ça vienne quelque part tu sais pas
comment dire
je peux comprendre qui aimait tant -
mettant qui est changé d beau métier
mais tant qu'il ya la noire cisco
lycéens félix donjon de la guide à moi
je m'attaque pas mal pour la limite ça
me fait rire le train je peux facilement
comprendre quelqu'un qui comprend pas du
tout petits qui réagit fortement ce jeu
peut forcément con principe c'est la
différence pis si drôle que tu parles
dessus parce qu'en ce moment il faut que
j'écrive serein essayait de comprendre
le paradoxe justement d'ouvrir branche
émancipation pilot pression qui manquait
un bout à mon âme mon chapitre qui était
explication de ce paradoxe et de
l'accord conflictuelle it et puis en
fait ce qui me manque je pense notre que
dans ce petit bout le pilote tu me fais
penser à ça c'est vraiment tout plein
réalité n'ont jamais été réunies
ensemble la musique on les six virtuel
donc avec le temps ça va se mélanger les
genres on se parle et ça va s'adoucir
mais le sicom un nouveau fac le sait
comme le chef bbc ce concert sera épicée
ces sociétés le discours antiféministe
et féministe bon c'est sûr quand ils
finissent c'est une réaction aux
féministes mais il ya beaucoup de jetons
qu'on ait beaucoup en réaction dans tout
type de discours on et en accenter les
positions féministes sont assez
prévisibles je veux dire c'est souvent
en réaction à et des fachos que ça en
général manque de nuance pas juste des
disques au féminisme et en général tout
type de discours pour moi manque de
nuance parce qu'on est beaucoup dans la
réaction mais ça vient aussi d'une
incompréhension et d'une colère
tu as fini batteries parce que donc 6 7
6 avait une dune et d'une
incompréhension d'une part de l'ordre et
que ces thérapies comme tu le dis
internet et les réseaux sociaux sont
extrêmement jeunes puis je pense qu'en
ce moment il ya des règles de civilité
qu'on n'a pas acquis mais qui sont
autres que ceux dans la vraie vie parce
que je pense que dans la vraie vie on y
aperçoit d'en face à personne de venir
dire ce qui est écrit sur le 6 mai
jamais pcc s'est donc je pense qu
éventuellement ça va peut-être
s'améliorer mais quand je regarde encore
une fois est ce qui se passe dans le
monde entier ça me fait pas parce qu'il
faut qu'on veut voir une tendance très
populiste vie extrêmement polluant c'est
justement puis bon le brésil a élu un
gouvernement d'extrême droite détaillé
souci un régime limite fasciste avec le
phénomène
les etats unis c'est ici foule ce qui se
passe dans notariaux j'ai l'impression
que ces disques auront une portée puis
en ce moment on est dans l'art du
populisme on est le réseau c'est
peut-être la dernière donnée cycle où je
sais pas on verra on verra ce que ça va
donner j'espère qu'il y aura du boulot
là dedans mais bon si on décide de
prendre en main notre planète va passer
c'est rare qu'on puisse parler de la
caverne vois ça c'est à l'espace non
traditionnels médiatique exactement qui
ne serait pas à occupation double
exactement ce qu'on veut faire
ni repas de montage faki merci tout le
monde si vous regarde pas là d'un côté
vous avez aimé ce que vous avez vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne pour
manquer aucun podcast qui va sortir à
chaque mardi
sinon commenté pour participer
discussions commenter ce que vous pensez
ce que vous avez entendu maintenant puis
nous on essaie de lire de répondre pi2
de participation et vous merci merci
merci paris
[Musique]